EVERYONE THE US SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM AND BEGINNERHEARING.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE TODAY FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WE REMOVED A
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO TELL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT FOR IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
AN MUTED NOW READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PARTY GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE.
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY. TWO BILLS
HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA THOSE BILLS ARE ITEM FOR
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR ALAN. AND ITEM TEN SB
1222% OF DOLLY. TO BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT THOSE BILLS ARE ITEM
FIVE SB THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR. BOB PORCHES AND ITEM
SIX SB ELEVEN THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR OCHO ABOUT. ONE BILL IS
A VOTE ONLY AS THAT BILL IS
BEING RECONSIDERED. THAT BILL IS
ITEM ELEVEN SB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
BEFORE WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION
ON BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR LEYVA
HERE LEYVA HERE OCHO ABOVE.
PHOTOBOOK HERE COURTESY. DELI
DELI HERE GLAZER. GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE. PAN HERE TENNIS HERE
YOUR SCORE. THANK YOU RAN
CONSOLE WE HAVE A QUORUM LET'S
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO
HAVE A MOTION. SO MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN MAN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT
SENATOR LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE OTOBO
AYE MITCHELL BOGART COURTESY.
DELI DELI HI GLAZER. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. TEN ALL RIGHT PAN I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL KEEP
THAT ON CALL FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE
NOT HERE YET ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM ELEVEN
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD IS A VOTE ONLY MET OF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. WE NEED A MOTION CONTROL MOVED
THANK YOU SENATOR OF CHOI BOGUE
. FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY LEYVA HI LEYVA HI
OCHO ABOVE I WHICH- BOGART
CORTESE. DELHI THIS IS A
REFERENCE BILL THAT'S VOTE ONLY.
OH OH SORRY NO. OH SORRY IT WAS
CLEAR YOU TO TALKING. SO IF YOU
WERE LISTENING WOULD HAVE HEARD
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO START OVER
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL ON
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
SENATOR BRADFORD'S BILL SO I'M
ASSUMING YOU DID NOT WANT TO
MOVE THE BILL. AT NO OKAY I ALSO
HEARD A MOTION BY SENATOR PANTS
TO THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THAT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
LEYVA HI RIVERSIDE CHOI BOGUE NO
A TROUBLED NO COURTESY. DOLLY
KELLY NOW GLAZER. MCGUIRE PAN HI
PAM I THINK YOU WILL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH OUR OTHER BILLS ARE CENTER
LA MONA AND NUMBER ARE NOT HERE
CENTER NIELSEN ARE YOU PREPARED
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN WITH.
BEGIN TODAY FOR US. YES IF YOU
WOULD STEP TO THE PODIUM THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. GREAT PLEASURE I COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY. TO SPEAK TO A
LONG AGO DREAM. THE DREAM BORN
SOME TWENTY ONE YEARS AGO IN A
SMALL OFFICE BUILDING FOR ABOUT
A HALF A DOZEN OF US SAT DOWN.
AND TALKED ABOUT. THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY. AND
HOW WE MAY BETTER EMPOWER. TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN CALIFORNIA
. AND THEN LATER IN AMERICA. WE
FOUNDED WHAT IS NOW CALLED WITH
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ASSOCIATION. THROUGH THESE
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF PAPA'S MAIN
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN A SCHOLARSHIP
. AN INTERNSHIP AND A VOTERS FOR
. ALL EXTRAORDINARILY SUCCESSFUL
. MANY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE ACCEPTED A POP
INTERNS IN THEIR OFFICES AND
MANY OF THOSE THE GAME THE
EMPLOYEE HERE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL. INDEED IT HAS ALREADY
BEEN SUCCESSFUL. SEVERAL YEARS
LATER. A POP BUT DECIDED TO GO
NATIONAL. I BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME
FORTY FIVE OR MORE CHAPTERS. NOW
THROUGHOUT AMERICA. OF A PAPA.
THE HEADQUARTERS THIS OUT IN THE
THOMAS. THE SENIOR STAFF OPERATE
FROM THEIR. COORDINATING AN
OPERATING WITH. THE LOCAL
CHAPTERS. EARLIER THIS YEAR AND
I BELIEVE THIS IS PROBABLY THE
FIRST BILL OVER THESE YEARS AT A
PAPA HAS SPONSORED. IT HAS
SUPPORTED MANY. AND THROUGH ITS
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE IT
SUPPORTED MANY CANDIDATES. AND
HELP ROOM THOSE CANDIDATES AGAIN
SEPARATELY THROUGH THE PACK
COMMITTEE. BUT THEIR CONCERN WAS
. IN K. TWELVE EDUCATION. THERE
NEEDED TO BE SOME INFORMATION
CONVEYED. TO OUR YOUTH. WITHOUT
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC GOT PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY. CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
IN AMERICA. AS FOCUSED IN
CALIFORNIA. WE LOOKED TO K.
TWELVE. AND WHAT THIS BILL
SIMPLY DOES IT IS NOT A MANDATE
NOT A REQUIREMENT. IT WOULD BE
THE RECOMMENDATION. THE API
MATTERS WE BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION. OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
THAT THEY MAY THEN BETTER KNOW
THE SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS.
THE HISTORY. IN FACT THE VERY
HISTORY OF THIS STATE IS
INTERLINKED. WITH ASIANS YOU
CAME TO CALIFORNIA. TO FOSTER%
AND ACHIEVE THE MODERN
MONUMENTAL. INTERCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD. THOSE CHINESE
INDIVIDUALS. BUT THEIR LIVES AT
RISK. THE CROSS THE SIERRAS. AND
BRING AMERICA TO THE WEST COAST. SO THIS BILL HAD SIMPLY
RECOMMENDS WITH CERTAIN CRITERIA. IMMERSION OR EXPOSURE TO IF
YOU WILL. STILL NOT A MANDATE IN
K. TWELVE. ELEMENTS ABOUT THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
. AND I HAVE TO SPEAK WITH JUST
A MOMENT OF PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
. DURING WORLD WAR TWO THE
ATTORNEY WAS A GREAT. DATE TWO
OF AMERICA. ALL WOULD CONCLUDE
AFTER THAT THAT WAS A MAJOR
MISTAKE. I GOT TO SEE SOME OF
THAT UP FRONT AND PERSONAL. SO
OUR NEIGHBORS WERE JAPANESE.
BOMBERS AND THEY WERE ENTERED.
MY DAD WAS ONLY ONE OF MANY- IN
OUR CASE WE ASSURED MANY E. THAT
WE WOULD TAKE CARE OF HIS LAND.
MAINTAINERS EQUIPMENT. WHEN THEY
CAME HOME. IT WOULD BE THERE FOR
HIM. I REMEMBER MY DAD SOME OF
THE ME ONE DAY AND SAY AND TAKE
THE TRACTOR. OVER TO BENNY. HE'S
BACK. AND HE NEEDS. WE WERE BUT
A SMALL EXAMPLE NOT EVEN THE
GREATEST EXAMPLE. OF MAKING LIFE
THE WRONG INFLICTED ON OUR
NEIGHBORS. SOON TURNED. SO THAT
WOULD BE MORE OF THE NEGATIVE
SIDE OF THE HISTORY THAT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS. A REIGION. IN
ALMOST EVERY SECTOR. SO THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE AS WE HAVE IN
OTHER SECTORS BEFORE. SOME
INSIGHTS FOR OUR YOUTH. ONE MORE
THING I MIGHT ADD ABOUT A POP.
WE DECIDED THAT WE WOULD BE AN
ASIAN OF AMERICAN PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ASSOCIATION. AT OUR INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM. SCHOLARSHIPS WOULD BE
FOR API YOUTH. BUT WE INCLUDE
ALL ETHNICITIES. IN ORDER VETS.
AND ARE PLANNING. IN OUR
DECISION. SO WE DO THROUGH A
PAPA NOT JUST PROMOTE ASIAN. AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS. I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY. AS A WITNESS. HE IS.
SOMEWHAT NEW TO THE ORGANIZATION
. HENRY CHANG ISTHE NATIONAL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A POP. HE
IS HERE WITH ANOTHER WITNESS
RENEE YANG WHO IS CO FOUNDER OF
TECH TEACH A. A. P. I. IF I MAY
INTRODUCE MISTER HENRY CHANG
ABSOLUTELY I THINK YOU'RE BOTH
YOUR WITNESSES ARE HERE IN
PERSON THEY ARE SO PLEASE STEP
UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES.
WE ARE ASKING FOR YOUR UNANIMOUS
VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY. BECAUSE
IT WILL SET UP POWERFUL MESSAGE
TO CALIFORNIA'S API COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE STATE AND LEGISLATORS
CARE ABOUT THE WILL BE ABOUT THE
WELL OUR WELL BEING. ABOUT
MAKING SURE OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. ARE NEVER AGAIN
THOUGHT OF WERE TREATED AS LESS
THAN FOR AMERICANS. AND THEY
NEVER HAVE TO EXPERIENCE THE
ALIENATING FEELING OF BEING
CONSTANTLY ASKED. SO WERE YOU
LOOKING FOR ARE YOU REALLY FROM
. THIS BILL HAS MASSIVE
GRASSROOTS MOMENTUM. AND IT'S
GROWING BY THE DAY IN JUST THE
PAST WEEK. THERE ARE FORTY NINE
DIVERSE ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THERE ARE SIGNED ON
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. IT OVER
THOUSAND LETTERS HAVE BEEN SENT
TO LEGISLATORS BY CONSTITUENTS
ASKING THEM TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
. THE CONTENT AND CURRICULUM FOR
EDUCATORS ARE EXIST FOR S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE. TO HAVE
IMMEDIATE IMPACT SOME EXAMPLES
INCLUDE MATURE MATERIALS FREELY
AND READILY AVAILABLE VICE
SMITHSONIAN'S ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN CENTER. PBS LEARNING
MEDIA. ASIAN EDUCATION PROJECT
OCA NATIONAL CURRICULUM PROJECT
. TEACHING MATERIALS CREATED FOR
H. I. HERITAGE MONTH HELLO THIS
GOES ON. ILLINOIS AND NEW JERSEY
. TWO STATES WITH APR
POPULATIONS OF LESS THAN ONE
MILLION. CAN YOU CAN YOU ONLY
ACCOUNT 44% OF API HATE
INCIDENTS COMBINED. HAVE ALREADY
PASSED FUNDAMENTALLY
FUNDAMENTALLY THE AME BILL AS
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE WITH
THE GOAL OF REDUCING ANTI ASIAN
HATE. WE CALIFORNIA I HAVE OVER
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION APR. ARE
CITY COUNCIL FORTY FOUR POINT
56% OF HATE INCIDENTS.
CALIFORNIA'S API COMMUNITIES AND
OUR CHILDREN ARE SUFFERING. WE
NEED TO TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION ON
THIS BILL. SEVERAL OTHER STATES
AT THIS POINT HAVE SIMILAR BILLS
IN PROCESS YOU COULD WRAP UP
MISTER CHANG SO I ASK YOU THIS
CALIFORNIA ON A LEED. OR FOLLOW.
PLEASE BONTA FAVOR THIS BILL
TODAY WE INVITE. ALL OF YOU TO
JOIN ON AS CO AUTHORS AS WELL
LET'S MAKE HISTORY TOGETHER
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND MS YANG ARE YOU HERE AS
WELL PLEASE COME RIGHT UP. GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY. CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN'T RATES. THE FOUNDING
OF TEACHING API WAS NOT A PRE
PLANNED EFFORT.AGAINST THE
BACKDROP OF COULD IT NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. MY CO FOUNDER
AND CO KNOW WHEN I CAME
TOGETHER. THROUGH UNFORTUNATE
RACISTEVENTS THAT HAPPEN TO
BOTH OUR KIDS SEPARATELY. WE HAD
BEEN UP TO THEN BEEN BARRED WITH
DAILY NEWS ON ANTI ASIAN RACISM
BUT IT WAS REALLY SEEN OUR SONS
MY SON OVER HERE GO THROUGH WHAT
HE WENT THROUGH. THAT HAS REALLY
SHAPED AND BECOME THE TIPPING
POINT OF WHAT IS TEACH APR TOUGH
FOR SHORT. TODAY TODD IS A
GRASSROOTS FAST GROWING
ORGANIZATION MADE UP OF A
COMMUNITY OF DEDICATED API AN
ALLY FAMILIES. OUR VISION A
SINGLE. TO ENSURE THAT WE CHANGE
THE PERCEPTION OF API BY
FOCUSING ON THE NEXT GENERATION
THROUGH DRIVING CURRICULUM
CHANGE IN SCHOOLS AND BEYOND.
FOUR APR CHILDREN THIS WORK
COULD NOT BE MORE CRITICAL TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR SENSE
OF IDENTITY TO THEIR SELF WORTH
FOR MY CHILDREN FOR ALL API
CHILDREN THEY SHOULD FEEL PRIDE
IN YOUR IDENTITY THEY SHOULD
FEEL THAT IN AND OUT OF THEIR
HOMES. THEY SHOULD BE YOUR
FREEDOM TO BE THEIR AUTHENTIC
SELVES AND A SENSE OF BELONGING.
YOU SHOULD NOT BE PRIVILEGES
THAT THEY CAN'T ACCESS AS
AMERICANS. I FOR ALL CHILDREN
NOT JUST API CHILDREN THIS WORK
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
INTEGRATING THIS CURRICULUM INTO
SCHOOLS ENABLE CHILDREN TO GAIN
A MUCH BROADER MORE REALISTIC
FRAME OF REFERENCE. BOTH
WIDENING AND DEEPENING THEIR
LANDS SO THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS
OF AMERICANS CAN BE MORE
CAPABLE. MORE EMPATHETIC AND
MORE POWERFUL. THIS BILL IS THE
BILL THAT WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR
IN THE PAST YEAR TAK HAS
CONNECTED WITH HUNDREDS OF
PARENTS SCHOOLS IN BOTH PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC SETTING WE HAVE
ADVOCATED WE HAVE PUSHED FROM
THE GROUND UP WITH AN URGENT
MANNER AND DONE IT WITH THE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND APPROACH
SCHOOL BY SCHOOL EDUCATOR BY
EDUCATOR WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
THE REPORTS OF THIS WORK. BUT WE
CANNOT DO IT ALONE WE NEED TO
WIDE REAR CHAMBER FAR CHANGING
CHANGE WITH THE CONTINUED
ONSLAUGHT OF WHAT IS GOING ON
REDEFINING HOW AMERICANS SEE
ASIAN AMERICANS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT WORK AHEAD AND THIS
BILL IS GOING TO HELP A LONG WAY
IN DRIVING THIS CHANGE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS DO
WE HAVE ANYONE EXCUSE ME
AUDIENCES ARE AND WHEN THE
AUDIENCE WHO'S HERE TO SUPPORT
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE IF SO
PLEASE COME THE MICROPHONE.
STATE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
MY NAME IS CHARLOTTE DANIELSON
CHANG I AM THE MOTHER OF TWO API
CHILDREN. I AM AN ATTORNEY BY
PROFESSION AND HAVE LOOKED INTO
THIS BILL VERY CAREFULLY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS DOMINIC
GAME AND I HAVE I AND MY MOM'S
SON. I'VE BEEN. LOOKING FOR THIS
BILL AND I REALLY SUPPORT IT
SINCE I'M ASIAN AND I- WITNESS
THIS MOMENT THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS ERIN DOES I'M A RECENT
GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS ON THE
CHILDREN OF FILIPINO IMMIGRANTS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS CALVIN
CHIANG AND- I AM OF A BUSINESS
LAWYER AND A FORMER WE A
ORGANIZER WITH FROM EACH YEAR
ALREADY- LOCAL TO IN SAN
FRANCISCO HOTEL REP AND
RESTAURANT WORKERS EMPLOYEES
UNION. ENDS FATHER OF TWO AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
SEEN NO ONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. MODERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO STATE THEIR
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN. AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISHED YOU CAN SUPPORT A
SB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWENTY THREE IN
THE QUEUE AND THE NUMBER IS
RISING ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MY
FIFTEEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAROLYN DOUBLE RAIL AND MEMBER
OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE CHINESE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF FOLLOW
COUNTY. WANTED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND ALSO AS AN AGENT FOR
CHANGE IN IN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ROLAND OF PUBLICADOS I AM A
FILIPINO PARENTS OF THE BACK
LITTLE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT IN
MAKE UP STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT
THE- MY THIRTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
GLORIA CHENG YET I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CHINESE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN LOS ANGELES. ANY
CONCERNED PARENT- IMPORTANT
MEMBER OF TEACH API IN LOS
ANGELES- I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AFTER REVIEWING IT. NINE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANISHA NICOLO
JAPANESE AMERICANS I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL A MEMBER OF
PEACH API THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CONNIE CHAN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST FOR THE STATE TREASURER
YOUR MOM I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE TREASURE AND WE
THINK THAT OUR NIELSEN FOR
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS DAVID COME ALONG AND ALLOW
XIN AMERICAN FOR THE MOST OF
WHAT MEMBER OF FLY FISHING
BUSINESS CLUB AS WELL AS GLOBAL
GLOBAL HERITAGE ALLIANCE. I'M
CALLING IN TO FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANTONIO
CO FOUNDER OF PEACH API DOT ORG
I AM A PROUD LOOK. I CAN MOTHER
OF TWO BOYS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. NINE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY THIRTY SIX YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS MANAGED.
IN THE FIRST ITERATION INDIAN
ANY ASIAN AMERICAN AND CONCERNED
PARENTS. HERE CARL AND I SUPPORT
THIS BATTLE. LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MERRY CAROL I'M
A SENIOR ASIAN STUDIES MAJOR AT
CSU SACRAMENTO AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
. NINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE
TWENTY TWO YOU MAY BE A NEW
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH
HI I'M MARY LOU HI EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER FOR DRIVING
PEAK A LOCAL NONPROFIT HERE I
GAVE IT. A MOTHER OF TWO AND
ALSO NATIONAL PRESIDENT OF A
PATH THAT AND I DRUNKENLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ONE THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANALYST- A
LOCAL BUSINESS OWNER IN
SACRAMENTO AND ALSO- API
DIFFERENT AND A LOT OF MOTHER OF
THREE CHILDREN AND I WILL BE
STRONG SUPPORT SYSTEM. NINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JACKIE RIGHT TOMORROW.
TRANSAMERICAN AND- SMALL OWNER
AND ALSO A FATHER OF THREE HI
STRONG SUPPORT SYSTEM OKAY THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY SIXTY
ONE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS BETTY LOU. I AM A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER OF TORRANCE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT LOCATED IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. I'M CALLING IN
TO PERSONALLY FEEL STRONGLY
SUPPORT. DR NIELSEN I MEAN
SENATOR NIELSEN- BUILT. NINE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALAN. I WANTED TO EMIGRATE
MOTHER AS WE HILL FOUND-
FOUNDING BOARD MEMBER PTA YEAH I
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIKE SIXTEEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LIKE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIFTY TWO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE.
MY FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME MADE THE WHEN I AM- FIRST
GENERATION OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS. AND I AM A FATHER OF
TWO AND I'M STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SYLVIA CHANG I'M A SECOND
GENERATION CHINESE AMERICAN FROM
BURLINGAME CALIFORNIA. A FEW AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT ITSELF THANK
YOU. NINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME ON THE PMR PROVOCATIVE AND
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I'VE
BEEN HERE FOR. A YEAR I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. NINE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S KEVIN COUPLE
OKAY I'M A JAPANESE AMERICAN
FATHER OF TWO DAUGHTERS MY
FATHER WANTED INTERMENT CAMP AS
WELL AS MY TWO GRANDPARENTS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SPELL. NINE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE SIXTY TWO
YEAR MAY BE A NEW PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY AT THIS IS A
DRAG HOW PUBLIC MANAGER FOR TO
TELL YOU CAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
. I LIKE HOW THIS IMMIGRANTS AND
WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT SB ONE
THREE SIX THREE THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT YOU MAY BE A NEW PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING EVERYBODY MY NAME'S
REGINA PAL I'M NOT COUNTY
UNIVERSITY STUDENT I FULLY
SUPPORT THAT YEAH THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING HONORABLE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BANGKOK
ANTICIPATION MILLION AMERICANS
SACRAMENTO THE UC DAVIS STUDENT
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE
I GREW CONNECT ALL DEFENSE
EDUCATION BUT RIGHT. EIGHT THE
WAY THAT IDEA WHILE THE
HIGHLIGHTS IS THAT OUR STORY AND
HISTORY THANK YEAR THANK YOU. BY
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO PAUL
SORIANO I WOULD CONCERNED
CITIZENS THE RECENT GRADUATE TO
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM STRONG
SUPPORT SPELL. NINE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ARE WE BLANCA
FLORIN- IMMIGRANT FROM THE
PHILIPPINES. AND ALSO
REPRESENTING A NICER COLUMBUS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LIKE EIGHTY YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
CONFINEMENT CAN YOU HEAR ME IF
WE CAN. HI I'M CALLING. FOR
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT MAKE SURE.
YES YOU ARE STAY IN THE QUEUE
WILL GET YOU WHERE YOU GET TO
THAT BILL NEXT CALLER PLEASE YES
I TOLD. YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THE BOARD OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WHICH I HAVE NONE
LISTED SO WE WILL COME HERE TO
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE HERE IN THE
PRO. SEEING AND HEARING NO ONE.
MATAMATA WRITER IF YOU COULD
BRING UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE. THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION O SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT BEGAN IT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN A
POSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE IMAGE PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE NINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE
BILL HAS. I FIXED OAKLAND SORRY
WE LOST ONE FIFTY NINE. IF YOU
JUST A MOMENT WE HAVE ONE MORE
LINE IN Q. ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY WE HAVE
NO RESPONSE FROM ONE TWENTY
EIGHT WE HAVE NO FOR THE COME
ALONG. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS CHILDREN PLAN I AM A
CHINESE AMERICAN A MOM OF TWO
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE LINE WAITING FOR A LINE
NUMBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS. GAINES AND I AM A
FOUNDER OF. FOR FOUNDER AND
BOARD MEMBER OF HALF SHEETS API
THE MOTHER OF TWO KIDS AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTED SPELL.
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY SIX LEVINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
FIFTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE NO RESPONSE FROM
LINE FIFTY. THREE HELLO YOUR
HONOR. HI MY NAME IS KEVIN FAN
AND I AM THE FOUNDER PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA AGENT
AMERICAN PROFESSIONAL SOCIETY.
AND WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THE BILL. AND NINE SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU NAY YAN AND- SOCIAL
WORKERS STRONGLY SUPPORT. SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
FOR SB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM MODERATOR ALRIGHT WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS TO
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND CHAIR AND- CENTER
NIELSEN I. PROVIDE ONE TO-
FREESHEET THANK AND APPRECIATE
YOU FOR YOUR- PARTICIPATION THE
FOUNDING OF A PROPERLY BELIEVE
YOUR WIFE IS ACTUALLY THE- THE-
SENIOR LEADER NOT PAPA SO- AND
SO APPRECIATE YOUR FAMILIES
INVOLVEMENT I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FAMILIES- HELP WITH
STUFF- WITH BY THE JAPANESE.
AMERICANS WHO WERE IN TURN I AM
HELPING THEM SAVE THEIR FARM AND
SO CERTAINLY YOU KNOW YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY'S COMMITMENT TO THE
API COMEDIAS APPRECIATED- I DO
HAVE WHAT DO YOU DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL- I'VE
HEARD NO TESTIMONY TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT PASSIONATE TESTIMONY
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING API EDUCATION ADDRESSING-
API HATE IN FACT- THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS LAST YEAR
AND- AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE-
WE FUNDED THE- API EQUITY
BUDGETS- TO ADDRESS- TO HELP
SUPPORT- SURVIVORS OF- EIGHTY I
HATE TO ACTUALLY FUND PROGRAMS
IN SCHOOLS. THAT'S WHAT HEARING
AID COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS- THE
BOWLING IS PARTICULARLY-
RACIALLY MOTIVATED ATTACKS AND
BOWLING IN FACT A RECENT STUDY
THAT CAME OUT SHOWED THAT OF ALL
STUDENTS- ACTUALLY API STUDENTS
WERE THE MOST TO REPORT- US
SUFFERING FROM- FROM THIS- AND-
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS
THEIR OFFICE SO THIS IS
CERTAINLY A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE
AND I APPRECIATE THAT- IN YOUR
TESTIMONY YOU POINTED OUT THAT-
HOWEVER IS THAT THE BILL ONLY
RECOMMENDS AND YOU'VE EMPHASIZED
IS NOT A MANDATE- AND- YOU KNOW
ANALYSIS. AND I GUESS WHAT MY
QUESTION IS THAT- EXACTLY.
THINGS THAT THE TEST FIRES IN
SUPPORT ACTUALLY SPOKE TO-
EXACTLY BY WHAT MECHANISM- WOULD
IT ACTUALLY LEAD TO ANY
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE SINCE IT IS A
RECOMMENDATION- AT THE ANALYSIS
TO TALK ABOUT ENCOURAGES THE
ENCOURAGES GOOD BUT- YOU KNOW
FRANKLY OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS MORE
THAN ENCOURAGEMENT WE'VE BEEN
AND- YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE IS
THAT- AS POINT THAT WE'VE- BEEN
SUBJECT SUBJECTS TO- TO HATE AND
HARASSMENT- JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF OUR RACE- THE- PANDEMIC BUT
EVEN PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC THESE
EVENTS HAPPENED SO. EXPLAIN TO
ME HOW THIS ACTUALLY. CHANGES
ANYTHING- WHAT IS WHAT EXACTLY
HOW EXACTLY IS THIS GOING TO.
ADDRESS- NO. STUDENTS ACTUALLY
LEARNING ANYTHING ABOUT THE API
COMMUNITY ASIDE FROM SIMPLY
ENCOURAGING AND- THAT- THAT THAT
SCHOOLS DO IT SO WHAT'S
MECHANISM BY WHICH THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY CARRY OUT AND ACTUALLY
LEAD TO CHANGE. WELL CENTER PLAN
I'D LIKE TO ALLOW. HIM TO EXPAND
THE COMMENT IS AS A SPONSOR AND
THEN I WILL TYPE IN. DROUGHT. HI
AGAIN I'M CHARLES MANSON CHANG I
AM OF THE NATIONAL. OPERATIONS
AND- BECAUSE- ACTOR FROM A PAPA-
IN ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION AS WE
KNOW- CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE EACH
SCHOOL DISTRICT NO MAÅR
THE STATE SAYS HAS THE ABILITY
TO INDEPENDENTLY OF JEWS WHICH
WHAT THEY PUT INTO THEIR
CURRICULUM. SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES RIGHT NOW IS WHAT IS
pNEW FRAMEWORK OR ANYTHING TO
HAVE THIS HAPPEN THERE ARE AND
I'VE ANALYZED EACH CODE SECTION
IN DETAIL EACH SECTION OF THE
CURRICULUM AND YOU'VE- YOU HAVE
AREAS WHERE THIS BILL VERY
SIMPLY ADDS IN- WHEN IT TALKS
ABOUT AMERICAN. SECTIONS EVEN IN
KINDERGARTEN AND FIRST GRADE OR
IT SAYS IN THE CURRICULUM TALKED
TO- THE AMERICAN HEROES- API'S
AREN'T LISTED ON THAT LIST WE DO
HAVE HARRIET TUBMAN AND CESAR
CHAVEZ AND- AND- YOU KNOW. THEY
WERE HAM LINCOLN AND ALL THESE
OTHER PEOPLE AND- EVEN SOMETHING
AS SIMPLE AS ADDING AN API-
CONTRIBUTORS TO SOCIETY FIXES A
LOT OF WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
CHILDREN. AS YOU KNOW WE ALREADY
HAVE- THE ETHNIC STUDIES BILL
THAT'S GOING THROUGH IN HIGH
SCHOOL- THAT WILL AT SOME POINT
MANDATE EDUCATION AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL AND WE ARE ASKING
FOR THAT MECHANISM EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA DID A GREAT JOB. THIS
IS SAYING- HEY SCHOOL DISTRICT
AS A BOARD AS A LEGISLATOR IT
SAYS THIS IS OF HIGH IMPORTANCE
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE IT
IS IN THAT SENSE AND MANDATE
SAYING THIS LEGISLATOR SAYS THIS
IS A HIGH PRIORITY ISSUE SO THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT GOES OUT TO
EVERY SCHOOL BOARD IN EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT SO IT HAS THAT
POWER WITH IT WE DON'T NEED NEW
CURRICULUM TO BE DEVELOPED AS
HENRY CHANG MENTIONED- THERE'S
ALREADY A LOT OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE- TO HAVE THIS HAPPEN
TO WE JUST NEED TO THE
LEGISLATOR TO SAY. YES WE
SUPPORT THIS AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS NEEDS TO BE PUT IN TO
ALL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA'S
CURRICULUM AND AGAIN WE'RE NOT
REINVENTING THE CURRICULUM WE
ARE SIMPLY INSERTING A API
AMERICANS THROUGH VARIOUS PARTS
OF THE CURRICULUM WE HAVE A
WHOLE STUDY WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ADD IN THERE- AND I'VE GONE
THROUGH SECTION BY SECTION WHICH
CURRICULUM POINTS- WOULD WOULD
NEED. TO COULD SIMPLY BE ADDED
AND THESE ORGANIZATIONS AS
MENTIONED WE HAVE FOURTEEN
HUNDRED INNOVATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THE CURRICULUMS
DEVELOPED IN ALL DIFFERENT AREAS
WE JUST NEED THIS LEGISLATOR TO
SAY THIS IS A HIGH PRIORITY AREA
WE DON'T NEED THIS MANDATED WE
NEED THE LEGISLATOR TO SAY THIS
NEEDS TO HAPPEN. WE ABOUT THIS
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR
NIELSEN DID YOU ALSO WANT TO
CHIME IN. INDEED THIS IS A
MOVEMENT. AND MOVEMENTS MOVE
THANKS WE'VE SEEN THIS COME
SWEEPING ACROSS THE LAND NOW
WITH. VARIOUS ASPECTS. OF K.
TWELVE EDUCATION. AND A
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY I THINK
WE HAVE BEEN AS A STATE
SENSITIVE AS DEMONSTRATED HERE
IN TESTIMONY. TO THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY.
MAYBE IN PARK THE FEELING BAD
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
INTERNET. BUT NONE THE LESS A
PLUS. AND THAT WAS WHAT I CALL
MORAL SUASION. AND THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THAT IS A
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS A TREMENDOUS
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL
BE VOICING THEIR OPINIONS. THE
LOCAL PEOPLE. WHATEVER THE CHORE
OF THE LEGISLATURE SAYING WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THESE
ISSUES ARE IMPORTANT THEY THEN
DISTRICT BY DISTRICT BOARD BY
BOARD TO TAKE UP THE CALL. THAT
IS DISTRICT. IT CANDIDLY A LOT
OF MEMBERS. AND IN EDUCATION AS
WELL AS IN THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
SOME APPREHENSION ABOUT MANDATE
. IT'S A SENSITIVE ISSUE.
UNFUNDED MANDATES IN THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS UNFUNDED
MANDATES FOR EVER. AND WE'RE
STILL GOING. I THINK THAT IS A
NEGATIVE. THE SOCIETY THIS
SUASION CARRIAGE PURCHASE AND IT
CARRIES PURCHASE BECAUSE I THINK
JUST LIKE THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY I THINK MOST
CALIFORNIANS CARE. THEY ARE
ADVOCATES THANK CENTER NIELSEN
CENTER PANTRY OF FURTHER
QUESTIONS- YES ACTUALLY- MASON
COMETS SO FIRST OF ALL- I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT TESTIMONY SAYING
THAT THERE'S CURRICULA OUT THERE
SO FORTH AND THERE'S LESS THAN
ACTED OUT SPEAKS TO THE
CHALLENGE RIGHT- THAT- THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE A LIST OF AMERICAN
HEROES AND NONE ARE ASIAN
AMERICAN WE KNOW THERE'S MANY
OUT THERE- I WOUL ALSO HOWEVER
POINT OUT THAT- IS CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER LET'S
LEAVE CAUCUS WE HAVE HEARD FROM-
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
ACTUALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BILL BECAUSE- IT- DOESN'T
ACTUALLY SEEM TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE. AND I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT SO I THINK FOR MANY MEMBERS
ON THE COMMITTEE WHO. WHETHER
IT'S YOUR GENDER OR YOUR RACE OR
SO FORTH- IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
MORAL SUASION BUT- OFTENTIMES IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO REALLY MOVE THE
NEEDLE VERY MUCH. BY ITSELF. AND
SO- AND- THANK- IN FACT THERE
WAS REFERENCE MADE IN THE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SOME OF
THE LAWS IN THE OTHER STATES.
THOSE LAWS ACTUALLY MANDATED.
TEACHING OF API I HISTORY IN THE
CURRICULUM THEY DIDN'T SIMPLY
SAY SUGGEST THEY MANDATED IT
BECAUSE I KNEW A SUGGESTION WAS
NOT ENOUGH. AND I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT YOU KNOW WE PASSED AND
WITH THE L. A. P. I. CARCASS WAS
PART OF THE SUPPORT FOR- THE
REQUIREMENT FOR ETHNIC STUDIES.
WHY DID WE PASS A REQUIREMENT
FOR GRADUATION EPIC STUDIES. AND
TELL IT AND IT WAS BECAUSE- IT
WASN'T HAPPENING IN FACT WE HAD
THIS DISCUSSION HERE ABOUT
REQUIRED FOR ETHNIC STUDIES AND
YOU KNOW AND I HAVE MY OWN YOU
KNOW ISSUES IN TERMS OF HOW IT
IMPLEMENTS BUT IN THE END. IN
ORDER TO MAKE IT HAPPEN AND
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT HOW DECADES
LATER- NOTHING HAPPENED. SO- YOU
KNOW BUT I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN SOME COMMUNICATION WITH THE
PAPA ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS
BILL IS NOT READY DATA WE NEED
TO DO MORE WORK- TO MAKE IT MORE
SENSITIVE AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT THIS BILLS COMING BEFORE US
IN THIS CURRENT FORM AND- SO-
YOU KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF THAT
UNFORTUNATE I'M NOT ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- BECAUSE-
WE THINK THAT OUR COMMUNITY THE
API COMMUNITY. DESERVE SOMETHING
MORE SUBSTANTIVE. THAT WE DON'T
WANT YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT
BOMBING ALREADY THAT CAN SAID BY
THE WAY YOU KNOW WHAT. WE'RE
JUST GONNA SUGGEST THINGS FOR
YOU IT'S TIME FOR REAL ACTION
THE API HATE IS REAL. THE
SUFFERING A COMMITTEE IT IS REAL
AND IT'S HAPPENING NOW SO- IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE FIRMER
STEPS. TO ADDRESS THESE THINGS
THE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE PROPER ON THESE ISSUES. BUT
ARE FRUSTRATED THAT THERE HASN'T
BEEN A BROADER DIALOGUE ABOUT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND WE SHOULD
FOLLOW THE LEAD TO SOME THE
OTHER STATES THAT ACTUALLY
MANDATE CURRICULA. THERE'S OTHER
STATES THAT WERE MENTIONED IN
THE TESTIMONY SO- AGAIN CENTER
RESIN I APPRECIATE YOUR PAST
LEADERSHIP AND THE SUPPORT FOR
THE API COMMUNITY- BUT AND I
THINK WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE
ABOUT THIS BEFORE. THIS BUT WE
COULDN'T. JUST DOING SOMETHING
IS. THE THAT IS A SUGGESTION I
THINK IT'S NOT SUFFICIENT FOR A
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. UNDER THE
PLAN WITH YOU PROPOSED AN
AMENDMENT WHICH I WOULD ACCEPT
MANDATING IT. SO WHAT I WOULD
SUGGEST IS THAT WE ACTUALLY AND
I THINK- THE- POINT OUT IS THAT
WE NEED TO DO WORKS TO ON ITS
AGAIN TO. SAY THAT IT'S THAT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS AND AGAIN I WISH THAT
THE THAT THE- SPONSORS THE BILL
HAD COME APPROACH YOUR CAUCUS OF
PRIOR TO BILL SUBMISSION
DEADLINE. SO YOU CAN WORK ON
GETTING SOMETHING MORE
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHT THAT ACTUALLY-
POINTS OUT THE VARIOUS AGENCIES
IN OUR STATE AND OUR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY NEED TO TAKE ACTION SO
WE COULD BE MORE SPECIFIC. AND
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY. RIGHT HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY- FOR THE THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE DONE TO BE SURE
THAT- ALL THE CHILDREN AND I
HAVE CHILDREN IN SCHOOL TO IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THAT THE
CHILDREN- ACTUALLY. WILL
ACTUALLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN. ABOUT THE HISTORY OF THE
ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND- SO WE COULD BUILD ON ETHNIC
STUDIES REQUIREMENT THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS WE CAN DO BUT I
MEAN THIS BILL IS FAIRLY SILENT
ABOUT ALL THAT. IT DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT MECHANISMS RIGHT IT SAYS.
IT'S AN EFFORT THAT'S MADE TO
THE IMPRIMATUR RIGHT OF THE
LEGISLATURE JUST DOING A BILL
AND SAY I LIKE THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE BILL. BUT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENTS THERE'S NO TALKING
ABOUT WHICH AGENCIES ARE WHO
SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE SCHOOL
BOARDS THAT THEY SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE IN SOME WAY
FURTHERING THE IMPLEMENTATION.
SO AGAIN YOU KNOW WE HAD
SUGGESTED THAT- THERE'D BE MORE
IN DEPTH CONVERSATIONS. AND-
AFTER YOU KNOW THE- A TICKET TO
FOR THIS OUT- A DUST TIME AND
EFFORT TO DO SO- AND- YEAH WE-
SO. STOOD TO DO THAT WORK OF
UNFORTUNATE WORK HAS NOT BEEN
DONE YET. AND SO THAT'S SO
THAT'S PROBLEMATIC. SPEAKING OF
SNOW FONTENELLE. SENATOR PAN
YOU'RE DONE ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS YES CENTER CORTESE.
YES IT IS IT WAS BECAUSE JUST
FOR A MOMENT- AND CENTER PANEL
ME TO SAY AS OF THOSE OF QUALIFY
HER THAT- I'M NOT. OBVIOUSLY I'M
NOT- A MEMBER OF THE API
COMMUNITY I COMPLETELY RESPECT
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT THE NEEDS TO GO. TO GO
FURTHER- AND- I DON'T KNOW
AMENDMENTS WERE WERE OFFERED IN
THAT REGARD I'M NOT THAT UP TO
SPEED ON WHAT WAS GOING ON
BETWEEN THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR OF THIS- WHAT AID TO
FIND. SOMEWHAT COMPELLING HERE
TO **** ME JUST A COMPELLING
OPPO'S THE SOURCING IS SOMEWHAT
COMPELLING- HAVING GROWN UP IN A
IN AN IMPROVING BERMAN ASSEMBLY
CENTER NIELSEN. WITH JAPANESE
AMERICAN NEIGHBORS- AS WAS THE
CASE WITH MY FATHER WHO IS A
YOUNG MAN DURING THE INTERMENT.
WHO ALSO SERVED IN SWORDS AND
TRIED TO CARRY THOSE THOUGHTS
FORWARD- MY NEIGHBOR. SERVED IN
THE FOUR HUNDRED FORTY SECOND-
WHICH WAS OF THE GREATEST COHORT
AND WILL WORK OF FIGHTING AND
WANT SOME OF WHOM- YOU WERE WERE
IMMIGRANTS HERE IS AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW. EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THEM HAS BEEN DECORATED BY
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS WERE
OFFERED TO BE DECORATED- TO CALL
OUT ATTENTION TO SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY NOT MENTIONED AS
FAR AS I KNOW ANY HISTORY BOOK
WHATSOEVER NOR IS THERE ANY
LEGISLATIVE INTENT- SPOKEN. TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW IN TERMS OF
LOCAL CONTROL BOARD TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT THEY SHOULD BE.
TELLING THAT STORY- THE END- AS
A AS AN ITALIAN AMERICAN IT'S
EVEN WORSE BECAUSE TELOMERIC INS
WERE INTERNED DURING WORLD WAR
TWO AS WELL- AMONGST. MY
ANCESTORS INCONCURRENT PLAYERS
NEED TYLER COMMITTEE THAT'S
CALLED THE SECRET HISTORY OF
AMERICA IN TERMS OF ITALIAN
AMERICANS I WOULD. I DON'T
INTEND TO BRING A BILL FORWARD
LIKE THAT BUT I WOULD LOVE IT IF
THERE WAS A BILL IT SIMPLY SAID.
OF THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. DECLARES THAT IT'S
IT IT'S INTENT THAT THAT STORY
BE TOLD IN SCHOOLS. THROUGHOUT
AMERICA WOULD BE BETTER. IF
THERE WAS A MANDATE THAT IT BE
INCLUDING CURRICULUM AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU SAID YES BUT I'M
NOT SURE. I WOULD VITIATE THE
BILL THAT AT LEAST THE COLORS.
THIS IS THE STORY AND IT NEEDS
TO BE TOLD. IT NEEDS TO BE TOLD
THAT'S A SUGGESTION. BUT IT'S
ALSO STATEMENT OF LEGISLATIVE
INTENT AND I DO THINK. THERE'S A
LONG HISTORY. A SHORT AS I'VE
BEEN HERE A LONG PROUD HISTORY
OF THE LEGISLATURE- IN. VIEW IN
A OWN LEGISLATIVE INTENT BECAUSE
OF SOMETHING WITH GROW. AND
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD GRAVITAS
SO. AND I'M- A LITTLE BIT IN THE
BECAUSE I AGREE. IN A RESPECT
PROBABLY MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM YOUR OPINION ON
THIS- BUT I'M NOT SURE. I THINK
I NEED TO BE AND I BOTH BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE OUT UNDER
THAT THE JUST THE NOTION- THAT
THIS IS. A BABY A SMALL STEP BUT
A STEP FORWARD YOU DON'T GET A
BROAD DECLARATION. IS INTO A
MUCH BIGGER ISSUE THAT WE NEED
TO DEAL WITH. THEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU SENATOR
OPPORTUNITY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS OKAY BEFORE WE
GO TO YOU FOR YOUR CLOSER
NIELSEN I WOULD JUST SAY THANK
YOU FOR BRING THE BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU DEAR SPONSORS THANK
YOU TO ALL THE FOLKS WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED- WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
SENATOR PAM WE PASSED BILLS ALL
THE TIME IN THIS HOUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY TEETH IN THEM. AS
YOU WERE WONDERING ABOUT THEM
THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM- BUT
IT IS ABOUT A MOVEMENT AND IT
IS. PEOPLE BEING ENGAGED AND THE
YOU KNOW SAYING THAT THIS IS
WRONG IN MAKING A STATEMENT OF
OUR VALUES- AND I THINK THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS INDICATED THAT HE
WOULD BE WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU- TO MAKE IT A MANDATE OR PUT
UP A LITTLE MORE TEETH INTO THE
BILL SO. I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
WILL BOTH WORK TOGETHER IF YOU
SO CHOOSE- BUT I THINK I THINK
IT'S A GREAT BILL AND I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO RESPECT ALL OF
YOUR- SUPPORTERS WHO'VE COME
HERE TO- TESTIFY CENTER NIELSEN.
AND APPRECIATE THEM FOR WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND TRYING TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER NIELSEN.
WELL I THINK YOUR COMMENTSAND
OBSERVATIONS OF YOU AND THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM THE VALLEY. REALLY. EMPHASIZE THE POINT. FOR THE
FOR. AGAIN THESE. STATE BILL.
OUR EVERYDAY OF HERE. AND SOME
OF THEM ARE MEANINGLESS AND
NOTHING MORE THE STATEMENT THAT
I VOWED LONG AGO WHEN I GOT HERE
I WAS NOT HERE EACH STATEMENT
BILLS I DO NOT LOOK AT THIS AS A
STATEMENT BILL. I LOOK AT THIS
IS A RALLY THE TROOPS BILL. AND
OF COURSE ON SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT AND YET NEGLECTED.
THAT WOULD BE MY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER NIELSEN WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE BILL THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY
AMENDED CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI- TOWBOAT. ADOBO BAG
COURTESY HI COURTESY I DALLI.
DALLI AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN. ALL RIGHT THAT BILL
IS OUT BUT WE WILL KEEP IT ON
CALL FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO THE TOP OF OUR ORDER THANK
YOU CENTER NELSON CHAIR THANK
MIGHT WELCOME. UP TO THE TOP OF
THE ORDER SENATOR LEE MON IS
HERE TO PRESENT SB TEN FORTY
SEVEN SENATOR BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR AND SENATORS SB TEN
FORTY SEVEN MAKES SEVERAL
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO OUR CURRENT
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM PARTICULARLY
BY MAKING ENROLLMENT EASIER. FOR
PROVIDERS AND FAMILY AS WELL AS
PROVIDING MORE CARE TO TODDLERS.
AS A WORKING MOTHER WITH AN
INFANT I HAVE STRUGGLE WHICH
HEALTHCARE OPTIONS MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FACE THIS SAME
STRUGGLE. CURRENTLY OUR SYSTEM
IS ONLY SERVING 10% OF ELIGIBLE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS. THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR INFANT AND
TODDLER CARE. AND SB TEN FORTY
SEVEN WILL MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
INEFFICIENCIES IN THE SYSTEM. SO
IT CAN BETTER SERVE TODDLERS
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS. THIS
BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
CHANGES BUT ALLOWS. CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO BE. IN PARENTS FOR
MORE FLEXIBILITY. FIRST THIS
BILL WILL OPEN UP THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. TO CHILDREN
FROM EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO FIVE
YEARS. FINALLY THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE IT EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO
ENROLL AND FIFTEEN WORLD IN
CHILD CARE. IT EASES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON PARENTS
AND PROVIDERS BY ESTABLISHING A
TWENTY FOR TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OF
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY. AND
ALLOWING FOR CATEGORICAL
ELIGIBILITY. IF A PARENT CAN
SHOW THAT THEY ARE ENROLLED IN
OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICARE
ALL. CALFRESH WICKET AND HEAD
START THEY ARE PRESUMED ELIGIBLE
FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE. TODAY
WITHOUT ME I HAVE NINA BT FROM
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA AND I
READ BERNARDO APPARENT TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. TERRIFIC
THANK YOU SENATOR LIMÓN AND I
BELIEVE BOTH OF YOUR WITNESSES
ARE CALLING IN. A MADAM A
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN OPEN THE
LINES FOR IRENE FOR NOT L. AND
THEN FOR NEED TO BIRTH THE-
BHUVI SARINA. AND BOTH OF YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. I REMEMBER AND
I DON'T. WE SURE CAN- GOOD
MORNING SENATE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND ENERGIZING BERNARDO AND MY
HUSBAND AND I LIVE IN HAYWARD
INFORMED DISTRICT HAS. BECOME
FORTY SEVEN BRIDESMAIDS. THANK
THEM CALIFORNIA PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM FOR YOUNG CHILDREN AND
MAKE IT EASIER FOR FAMILY TO
ACCESS IN CHILD CARE. MY FRIEND
THREE YEARS AND THE YOUNGEST. OF
BOTH OF MY BOYS I CAN AN IN AND
CARE IN I DON'T. HOWEVER WHEN
HIGH TURN THREE YET TO READ AND
GAMBLE HIM ANOTHER WHAT'S AND
YOU. HE HAD HEALTHCARE FOR
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
HELPFUL. IT'S BEEN GREAT TO HAVE
MY- CALLED AND THE THING. I'M
NOT EVEN LEARN HOW TO NAB
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND WITH THE
COLD DARKISH ALL DIFFERENT
ALREADY BEEN ATTENDING ANYTHING
UNTIL THE PRO. WELL MY PROCESS
THE MOMENT ACTUALLY. WORKED WITH
ME FOR A THREE HOUR THE PEOPLE.
TO
LIKE. YOU CAN RECTIFY WHAT I
APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS BILL IS
THAT IT CREATES CONTINUITY OF
CARE FOR CHILDREN TO MAKE CENTER
A PROGRAM THAT THEFIRST THE
WORLD IN YOU TO THE
RECERTIFICATION PROCESS HI AND
MY YOUNGER SON ARE NO LONGER THE
SAME CHILD CARE CENTER. IF I'VE
MADE MY COMMUTE VERY CHALLENGING
I ALSO HAD TO CUT BACK ON WORK
HOURS AND CANCEL MOST OF MY- AND
GAVE ACTIVITIES FOR MY FAMILY.
AT THE FORTY SEVEN TO MAKE LIKE
YOU CAN FOR PARENTS LIKE ME
ACTIVE QUALITY CHILDCARE
PRESCHOOL. THANKS FOR COMING TO.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NINA PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OUR CHAIRMAN LEYVA
AND COMMITTEE NUMBERS MY NAME IS
NINA THREE PM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COVERAGE HOW
CALIFORNIA A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
SIXTEEN HUNDRED EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROVIDERS AND A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BELT. I'M ASKING
HEARD SB TEN FORTY SEVEN WHICH
STRENGTHENED THE SUSPECT EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION PERCENT
ENABLE PROVIDERS TO BETTER SERVE
THE NEEDS OF OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILY ESPECIALLY TODDLERS WHERE
WE KNOW THERE IS THE GREATEST
NEED. AND ACCORDING TO THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE MASTER PLN ONLY
ONE IN FIVE CHILDREN WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE ARE CURRENTLY ENROLLED
IN STATE SUBSIDIZED CRIME. SB
TEN THIRTY SEVEN OPEN UP THE
PRISON PRO TO SEARCH. EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO FIVE RATHER THAN ONLY
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD IT ALSO
PROVIDES PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY I'M
TO TRANSFER BETWEEN. CONTRACTS
OUR GOAL WITH THIS BILL IS TO
EXPAND AGE ELIGIBILITY WHILE
MAINTAINING QUALITY TITLE FIVE
STANDARDS AN APPROPRIATE AGE
RATIOS. TO ENSURE THAT ALL
PROGRAMS CAN FULLY EXPAND THEIR
CONTRACTS AND SERVE THE CHILDREN
IN THEIR COMMUNITY. THERE'S ALSO
A NUMBER OF OTHER PROVISIONS IN
HERE SUCH AS PROVIDERS WOULD BE
REIMBURSED BASED ON CHILD
ENROLLMENT RATHER THAN
ATTENDANCE. PROVIDING MORE
STABILITY AND ENABLING FAMILIES
TO FULLY UTILIZE THEIR CONTRACT
FUNDS TO SERVE CHILDREN. RATHER
THAN RETURNING FUNDING TO THE
STATE. IT FURTHER EXPANDS FAMILY
CHILDCARE EDUCATION NETWORK SO
THAT FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
CONSORTIUM IN THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WHICH WE THINK
IS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
MORE CHOICES. FOR PARENTS AND
FAMILIES- ALSO MAKES CATEGORICAL
ELIGIBILITY THERE WHICH WOULD
REDUCE SOME OF THAT BURDEN SOME
PAPERWORK FOR FAMILIES AND
PROGRAMS. AND WE FEEL THAT IT
WOULD MOVE TOWARDS A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM FOR LOW INCOME
WORKING FAMILIES CAN GET TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS OF ELIGIBILITY FOR
CHILD CARE. SO THAT THEY WORK
AND THEIR CHILDREN CAN LEARN IN
A STABLE HIGH QUALITY
ENVIRONMENT. FOR ALL O THOSE
REASONS I URGE YOUR SUPPORT SB
TEN FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OR IT
WILL COME HERE TO ROOM TWENTY-TWO HUNDRED FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGAN. AND US
SUPPORT FOR BILL. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GETTING MY JAAN ON WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. RIGHT SEEING NO ONE
ELSE MADAM MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME
AND SUPPORT FOR SB TEN FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FORTY SEVEN. PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN FORTY
SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS THIS IS DONNA HOFFMAN
CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF COUNCIL
FOR A STRONG AMERICA READY
NATION FIGHT CRIME INVESTING
KIDS AND MISSION READINESS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE WHITE WITH
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILD CARE
NETWORK WE BELIEVE THE EIGHTEEN
MONTH OLD SHOULD BE IN GREAT
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES. REPORT
FINAL CHOICE YES HE PM THAT'S
LAWS THAT REGULATE WORKED WITH
THE SPANISH LANGUAGE DAMAGE OUT
THERE AND PFPT. THE YOU NEXT.
NINE ONE OH FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS PATTY
HERRERA ON BEHALF OF EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA CROWD CO SPONSOR OF
SB TEN FORTY SEVEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING LARA MACINNES STORY
HER ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN
DIRECTORS GROUP AND FORCE THE
CINEMA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
. NINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS MADE BY MARK
WITH CONVEYING GO WE'RE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR AT TEN FORTY SEVEN
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME OF THAT
PRODUCT- AND I AM A MOTHER TO
TWO CHILDREN I AM ALSO LISTED
INGLE AND I ONLY SUPPORT SB. TEN
FORTY SEVEN. LINE ONE OH SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CALLING
FACTOR ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND THE PART. AND ONE MOMENT FOR
UNEXPLAINED MEMBERS.
NINE ONE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY
NAME IS SERENA LANTERNS HANGING
OVER MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN TO
INVITE AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FORTY SEVEN I'M SORRY WE HAD
ONE QUEUE UP. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE ONE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ONE OH
EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT WE HAVE NO
RESPONSE FROM NINE ONE OH EIGHT.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR OR WHO
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION WE
WILL COME HERE ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB TEN FORTY
SEVEN SEEING NONE MADAM
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND OPPOSITION SB TEN
FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FORTY
SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FORTY SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
THERE. MY SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET
FIFTEEN DEBORAH I FEEL THAT
PARENTS SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN DAY CARE AND THE
PROJECT WILL DEPEND COUNTY
DAYCARE THANK YOU MA'AM NAME IN
OPPOSITION ONLY NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU CENTER FOR
BRING THIS FOR I KNOW THAT- WE
SUPPORTED THIS BILL LAST YEAR
AND SO. WHAT WHAT YOU'RE OUT OF
TAKE ON WHETHER IT'S GONNA GET
SIGNED AGAIN OR NOT BECAUSE IT'S
TYPICALLY THE XACTLY THE SAME
BILL THAT WE THAT YOU RAN LAST
YEAR I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
CHANGES THAT I NOTICED SO THERE
ARE SOME CHANGES ON OUR- YES SO
WE NO LONGER INCLUDE THE
PROVISION. BILL WERE THE PART OF
THE CONTRACTING NEGOTIATION
PROCESS LIKE MAKING
REIMBURSEMENTS BASED ON
ENROLLMENT SAID ATTENDANCE
THAT'S BEEN OMITTED FROM THE
BILL WE ALSO REMOVE THE
PROVISIONS ALLOWING FOR
PROVIDERS TO SHIFT BETWEEN. CCS
P. AND OTHER CONTRACTS BECAUSE
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- AND WE ALSO INCLUDED
PRIORITY FOR THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS SO THOSE ARE THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN LAST YEAR
AND THIS YEAR AND THE VETO
MESSAGE. AT WAS THAT IT WAS
PREMATURE AND IT WASN'T IN THE
BUDGET- IN THE JANUARY BUDGET-
THE GOVERNOR HAS SOME ELEMENTS
HERE ARE L. ON HAS SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE IN THE BILL
BUT OUR ELEMENTS FOR MORE
EXPANSIVE. SO FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET- THE GOVERNOR AT
PUT A PROVISION IN FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITY AND WE ADDED
STUDENTS- JUST. IN STUDENT- YOU
KNOW ANOTHER PROVISION IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET IS THAT IT.
STARTS AT TWENTY FOUR MONTHS WE
STARTED EIGHTEEN MONTHS SO
THERE'S DEFINITELY SOME
DIFFERENCES- BUT- THE ELEMENTS
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD ASKED TO
BE ADDRESSED IN THE BUDGET- ARE
IN THE GENERAL VERSION OF THE
BUDGET. SO THE FUNDING IS SO
THERE IS FINDING IT THAT GOES
WITH. IT'S IDENTIFIED FOR THIS
TYPE OF THE LEGISLATION IN YES.
AS IN THE JANUARY BUDGET I MEAN.
OKAY RIGHT WHERE THE PROCESS IS
RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU THANK
SENATE ALI ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS THE BILL
ALL RIGHT THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZERS AND
SENATOR PAN- IS THEIR LIMÓN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I.
THINK YOU BILLS REMOVED BY
CENTER GLAZER MADAM- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB TEN FORTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
LEYVA AYE. LEYVA ALL RIGHT UNTIL
A VOTE. WHICH- VOEPEL COURTESY
ALL RIGHT FOR TO THE I. DALLI.
DALLI AYE GLAZER. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN RIGHT
HAND ON. THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MATTER LIMÓN. SO
WONDERFUL TO HAVE A FULL
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR-
BURKE AND I THINK YOU BROUGHT
SOME FRIENDS. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY WE BROUGHT
SEVERAL FRIENDS. THAT CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I WANT O
PARTICULARLY THANK YOUR STAFF IN
OLGA LUCIA RAMIREZ FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL- TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT. SB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. AS THE FIRST STEP THE
FIRST STEP IN THIS PROCESS TO
REMOVE SARAN'S HASTINGS NAME
FROM THE COLLEGE OF THE LAW AND
PROVIDE SOME RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
. I'M I'M HERE WITH- JOINT
AUTHORS- SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
SENATOR WIENER- FOR THOSE OF YOU
DON'T KNOW UC HASTINGS IS THE
EXCELLENT INSTITUTION A-
WONDERFUL INSTITUTION IS
PROVIDED MORE JUDGES AND MORE
LAWYERS THAN ANY OTHER LAW
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA FACT WAS
THE FIRST LAW SCHOOL WEST OF THE
MISSISSIPPI. OF THE NUMBER OF
PROMINENT ONE NINE WHO HAVE
GRADUATED FROM UC HASTINGS AMONG
THEM ARE VICE PRESIDENT. WILLIE
BROWN. JACKIE SPEAR- THE ISSUE
THAT BRINGS US HERE TODAY THOUGH
IS LOOKING BACK IN THE HISTORY
OF SARANDA SEES THINGS WHO WAS
SADLY THE FIRST CHIEF JUSTICE
CITY CALIFORNIA- IN. HIS AXE
ACTIVITIES IN HORRIFIC ACTIONS.
IN A SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THE
HASTINGS LEGACY REVIEW COMMITTEE
DELIVERED A REPORT TO THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS THE DETAILED THE
FINDINGS OF SERENA'S HASTINGS
AND HIS INVOLVEMENT A SERIES OF
MASSACRES OF NATIVE AMERICANS
OTHER REPORT FOUND THAT HASTINGS
PLANNED AND FUNDED A SERIES OF
MASSACRES IN AROUND THE COUNTY.
OF MENDOCINO DURING THE EIGHTEEN
FIFTIES. WHAT'S IT COOLEY SAID
IS THE FACT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. REIMBURSED SARAN'S
HASTINGS FOR HIS EXPENSES IN
THIS MASSACRE OF THE SCHOOL HERE
HERE FROM TODAY ONCE THE
HASTINGS NAME REMOVED AS DO ALL
THREE OF US- DURING THE
COLLEGE'S FOUNDING PROCESS
HASTINGS HAD A PROVISION
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE. REQUIRING THAT
THE UNIVERSITY FOREVER BE KNOWN
AS THE HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE
LAW AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE REQUIRES A
STATUTORY CHANGE TO REMOVE HIS
NAME. OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO REMOVE
HASTINGS NAME FROM THE COLLEGE.
AND THAT'S THE WORK THAT WE'RE
BEGINNING HERE TODAY- THIS THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS- WE'VE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITYTO MEET WITH
PRESIDENT RUSS- AND WE HAVE
COMMITTED TO A CONTINUING
CONVERSATION ABOUT NOT JUST
REMOVING THE NAME HASTINGS BUT
ALSO. WHAT ELSE CAN BE DONE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WRONG AND TO
PROVIDE SOME SOME THE WRONG WILL
NEVER BE RIGHTED THE WRONG WILL
NEVER BE RIGHTED BUT TO PROVIDE.
SOMETHING TO RECOGNIZE THE
WRONGFUL BEHAVIOR OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND AMONG THOSE
IDEAS THAT ARE BEING DISCUSSED
AMONG THOSE IDEAS THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY EVEN REDUCED ALLEGE
COUNCIL SO THAT THE NEXT STEP IN
THE PROCESS OF FOR FORTUNATE TO
HAVE THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD. THE
THAT WE INCLUDE PORTIONS OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR EXAMPLE
PUBLIC MEMORIAL TO THE YOU KEEP
PEOPLE A WEBSITE TO ENGAGE THE
PUBLIC AND EDUCATE THE PUBLIC AS
TO THESE ATROCITIES AND HOWARD.
HOW WE'RE WORKING TO. ADDRESS
THEM TODAY A CLINIC EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM IN THE ROUND VALLEY
WHICH IS THE AREA THAT WAS MOST
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED AND THEN
THE NATIVE AMERICANS MOST
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED A PRO BONO
LEGAL SERVICES ESTABLISHING A
MUSEUM. A NATIVE AMERICAN LAW
PROGRAM ASSISTANCE IN OBTAINING
GRANTS AND STATE PROGRAMS IN A
NUMBER OF OTHER ITEMS AT THE LAW
SCHOOL IS DISCUSSING WITH THE
UKEE TRIBE IN THE ROUND VALLEY
DRIVE. THESE ARE JUST
RECOMMENDATIONS WE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN'T FOR IN A THESE
UPON. UC HASTINGS OF THE SCHOOL
I HOPE THAT WILL BE FORMALLY
KNOWN AS UC HASTINGS BUT BUT
THESE WILL BE OUR STRONG STRONG.
RECOMMENDATIONS OUT WITH ME HERE
IS OUR JOINT AUTHORS I MENTIONED
AT THE OUTSET SENATOR WIENER
CENTER WIENER. INTO THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG MORNING
COLLEAGUES I. TYPICALLY HAVE
MULTIPLE PRESENTERS- I'M REALLY
UNDER YOUR CENTER HERTZBERG AND
CENTER ON BURGER COULD ALUMNI IF
HE SINGS I HAVE THE HONOR OF.
REPRESENTING THE COMMUNITY THAT
INCLUDES UC HASTINGS SO IN MANY
WAYS THIS IS IN SOME WAYS THIS
IS A THIS IS IN PART A DISTRICT
ISSUE IT ALSO GOES BEYOND THAT
BECAUSE- OF THE ATROCITIES
COMMITTED AGAINST. OF THE IMPACT
OF DRIVERS FOR UC'S THINGS IS A
MAJOR- INSTITUTION IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IT
HAS. PRODUCED SIGNIFICANT
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP AND LEGAL
LEADERSHIP AND OUR CITY- AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
ALL VERY PROUD. OF THIS AMAZING
LAW SCHOOL IN SAN FRANCISCO. SAN
FRANCISCO THE SERVICES WERE ALSO
HORRIFIED- WHEN THEY LEARNED-
THAT- THAT MISTER HASTINGS OFF
FROM THE SCHOOLS NAMES. ARE
COMMITTED GENOCIDE- AGAIN
STRIDES LITERALLY ATTEMPTED TO
WIPE THEM OFF THE FACE OF THE
PLANET- AND WHEN AND
EXTERMINATED A LARGE NUMBER. OF
TRIBAL MEMBERS- AND HIS NAME
NEVER SEVEN PLACED ON THE SCHOOL
FROM THE OUTSIDE- BUT- AT SOME
POINT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT HAPPENED. AND
THEN MOVE FORWARD- AND SO IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'M HAVING THE NAME
HASTINGS ON THE SCHOOL IS A SCAR
ON OUR CITY PEOPLE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WANT THIS NAME GONE
THEY'RE PROUD OF THIS LAW CHOOL
WHO DO NOT WANT THIS NAME. TO BE
ON THE SCHOOL IT IS AN
EMBARRASSMENT FOR OUR CITY TO
HAVE A MAJOR INSTITUTION NAME
FOR SOMEONE WHO LITERALLY
EXTERMINATED NATIVE AMERICANS
LIVING IN THIS. OP ED AND ARE IN
OUR STATE- AND SO- IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR MY COMMUNITY THAT
THIS NAME BE STRIPPED OFF- OF
THE SCHOOL. IT IS ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT FOR MY COMMUNITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO- THAT WE DO WHAT
WE CAN TO SUPPORT THE TRIBES.
ARE THE IMPACT OF TRIBES- AND SO
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH UC
HASTINGS- AND OTHERS AND IT'S
BEEN MY HONOR TO BE IN MEETINGS-
BOTH LIVE AND THE ASSUME- WITH-
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES- AND THAT'S CENTER
ON BURKE MENTIONED- IT IS OUR-
INTENT AND WE WILL- MAKE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. TO
INCLUDE ELEMENTS OF RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE I IN TERMS OF TANGIBLE
WAYS OF SUPPORTING- THESE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THAT TO THIS DAY
SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES. OF
WHAT'S AROUND US HASTINGS DID A
HUNDRED SEVENTY YEARS AGO. THESE
THESE HARMS TO GO AWAY AND A FEW
YEARS. THEY CAN LAST FOR
GENERATIONS FOR CENTURIES AND SO
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE STEP
UP- ON THE USED NOT UC HASTINGS
BUT MORE BROADLY FROM THAT- STEP
UP TO SUPPORT THE TRIBES INTO
ENGAGE. IN RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
TO START TO START HEALING THE
HARMS THAT WERE CAUSED BY
SYRINGE HISSING BUT BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE WE KNOW
THIS STATE THAT WROTE THIS THE
IT WAS NOT UNFORTUNATELY STARTED
HIS IS NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO DID
US IN CALIFORNIA- AND THE STATE
WAS PART OF THIS FOR VARIOUS
TRIBES THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND
SO- I'M PROUD TO JOIN AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL I DO WANT TO SAY- THAT
IN TERMS OF THE NAMING- OF THE
SCHOOL THE UC HASTINGS BOARD
DIRECTORS HAS ON IT AS ADOPTED-
A MEASURE IN TERMS OF WHAT IT
WANTS ITS NAME- TO BE. OFFER ANY
SCHOOL HIGHER EDUCATION THE NAME
OF THE SCHOOL- IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT IN MY VIEW- THAT THE
THAT THE COLLEGE IN THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY- YOUR BE- OKAY WITH
WHAT THE SCHOOL'S NAME IS
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO LIVE WITH
THAT NAME FOREVER IN TERMS OF
THEIR STUDENT BODY. AND THEIR
ALUMNI AND SO ON AND SO FORTH-
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO.
WORKING UNDER THE A BILL THE
ASSEMBLY AS WELL BY SOMEONE
RAMOS- I HAVE PROBABLY HAD.
TWENTY DIFFERENT PHONE CALLS AND
MEETINGS WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO I HAVE MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALSO. A COMMUNICATED WITH
HIM- I KNOW THAT WE'RE ALL GOING
TO WORK TOGETHER. HASTINGS WITH
THE TRIBES OF MISTER RAMOS AND I
AM CONFIDENT THAT IN THE END WE
WILL HAVE ONE BILL THAT WE WILL
ALL BE BEHIND THAT I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD. TO THAT SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER CENTER
HERTZBERG. WITH SAID REALLY BEEN
HONORED TO WORK WITH MY- JOINT
AUTHORS ON THIS MEASURE THEY'VE
BEEN PASSIONATE THEY'VE DONE THE
HOMEWORK. AND SPEND JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF TIME AND
I THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH- AND
I'M POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
MANAGER WHILE I. WAS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OFREDLANDS WELL OVER
A DECADE BEFORE YOU WERE. I JUST
WANT THE RECORD TO REFLECT THAT
I WAS ALSO AT THE HASTINGS-
BEFORE- MADE JOINT AUTHORS
STROMBERG WAS MY- JUNIOR
COLLEAGUE HERE SO. HE'S ONLY A
YEAR AND I ALSO WANT I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYBODY HERE WOOD
I GUESS DR PASSER IN THE
ASSEMBLY DOTSON WILSON WAS IN
THE CLASS TWO. WHO IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
INSTITUTION I JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HIM ALWAYS
ACKNOWLEDGE HIM. I DON'T WANT TO
SAY IS THAT TO. HISTORY IS WHAT
IT IS WE CAN'T CHANGE IT. WE
HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION TO
CHANGE OUR RELATIONSHIP TO IT.
DO WE EMBRACE IT OR NOT- YOU
KNOW A HASTINGS IMPORTANT PLACE
THEY SAY IT'S THE- HARVARD OF
THE WEST I WOULD SAY HARVARD IS
THE HASTINGS OF THE EAST. FOR
THOSE GRADUATES OF THAT SCHOOL
OF LAW AND TELEVISION REPAIR BUT
IN ANY EVENT- HE WENT THERE ARE
. SO BUT I JUST WANT TO ADD ON A
DON'T THINK I NEED TO SAY
ANYTHING FURTHER IN TERMS OF THE
ISSUES AND THE LIKE I JUST DON'T
WANT TO STAND HERE IN SOLIDARITY
WITH MY WITH MY JOINT AUTHORS
AND TO- ALSO ACKNOWLEDGED
LEADERSHIP HASTINGS'S PUT JUST
AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF TIME
IN TWO MEETINGS SHOWING RESPECT
TO BUILDING THE RELATIONSHIPS
ARE ARE AND DOING WHAT'S
NECESSARY IN DEALING WITH THESE
KINDS OF VERY CHALLENGING
ISSUES. ANSWER CERTAINLY WOULD
ASK YOUR SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG DECEMBER DID YOU WANT
TO INTRODUCE YOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- WE HAVE A DEAN FIGMENT
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THE
INFECTION IS IN THE BACK ROOM
BUT IN TERMS OF WITNESSES OF
VIRGINIA ELIZONDO- IS ON THE
PHONE HEDGE OF PROFESSOR OF LAW
AT HASTINGS- AS WELL AS JOE
CARILLO WHO IS HERE PROFESSOR
LAW IN FACT THE DIRECTOR OF THE
INDIGENOUS LAWCENTER. AT THE UC
HASTINGS AND YOU HAVE A
PREFERENCE AS TO WHO GOES FIRST
WHEN WE GO WITH MISS- ELIZONDO
FIRST IF SHE'S AVAILABLE ON THE
PHONE ARGUMENTUM OPERATOR IF
YOU'LL PLEASE. QUEUE UP MS
ELIZABETH. AND SHE HAS TOO MANY
. HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS. I'M
HERE. YOU GO AHEAD MICELLES ON
THE OKAY GREAT THANK YOU. HELLO
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA DARI
UNDERSTANDABLE I'M A COLLEGE A
LONG QUESTION AB ONE AND AN
ADJUNCT PROFESSOR I TEACH THE
GOVERNMENT LAW CLINIC I WAS A
MEMBER OF THE COLLEGE OF LEGACY
COMMITTEE AND TRANSITION TO THE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE INVITES
REPORT I HAVE A BACKGROUND IN
AMERICAN INDIAN HISTORY AND LOCK
IN AGREED TO SERVE ON THESE
COMMITTEES. BECAUSE I STRONGLY
BELIEVE IN THE PRINCIPLE OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. I WANT TO
PUT MY AND PROFESSIONAL. TO USE
ADDRESSING THE ONGOING
CONSEQUENCES OF THE GENOCIDE
INFLICTED UPON THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE OF THE STATE. WE HAVE
REAL PEOPLE WHO WERE TREATED AS
INCONVENIENT. TO THE OWNERSHIP
OF CALIFORNIA'S GOLDEN
RESOURCES. I SUPPORT REMOVING
SERRANO FACING CLAIMS FROM THE
INSTITUTION THAT TRAINS SOME OF
THE FINEST LAWYERS MANY
DEDICATED TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
MANY ACTUALLY HERE IN HERE
HEARING WELL. WHAT LAW SCHOOL
CLASSMATES MY ALUMNI COLLEGE.
COLLEAGUES AND I WERE HORRIFIED
TO LEARN. OF THE COLLEGE
FOUNDERS ROLE IN THE GENOCIDAL
POLICIES THAT ACCOMPANIED THE
BILL RATES TO CHOIR LANDED
WELCOME CALIFORNIA. THIS STATE
WITH NO EXCEPTIONS TO THIS
SHAMEFUL HISTORY OF THE
TREATMENT OF INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
IN THE CONQUEST OF THIS COUNTRY
WHICH THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
ADVISORY BOARD AND THE COLLEGE
HAS MADE SOME PROGRESS WITH THE
DRAFTING. SHAMEFUL LEGACY.
ESTABLISHING THE INDIGENOUS
LAWCENTER. CREATING SPACE IN THE
LOBBY OF THE MADE IN
MINISTRATIONS BUILDING ON CAMPUS
TO COMMEMORATE AND HONOR THE YOU
KEEP PEOPLE. HOSTING CONFERENCES
AND SPEAKERS ON INDIGENOUS LEGAL
ISSUES. FUNDING PUBLIC INTEREST
FELLOWS IN THE CAR EUREKA TO
WORK ON INDIGENOUS LEGAL
MATTERS. BUT IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
YOU KEY DEFENDANTS. BROWN VALLEY
INDIAN COMMUNITY AMONG MEMBERS
OF THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
ADVISORY BOARD WE ALWAYS COME
BACK TO THE ELEPHANT AND- THE
NAME OF THE COLLEGE. IN ORDER TO
MOVE FORWARD WE HAVE TO CONFRONT
JEFF STREET NOT CONTINUE TO
DEBATE. IT'S AN HONOR TO HAVE
YOUR NAME ON A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION THE TERM OF CONQUEST
CANNOT BE ERASED OR MINIMIZED
BUT WE CAN TAKE THE SMALL STEPS
WILL BE MOVING THE HONORING OF
THOSE. WHO CONTRIBUTED TO THIS
TRAUMA. A BILL TO SIMPLY DO NOT
DESERVE TO BE SO ON EDGE. I
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING UP THE
TIME. MATTER AND ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MISS CARILLO YOU ARE
UP NEXT YEAR TWO MINUTES ALSO MY
NAME IS JOE CARILLO I AM
PROFESSOR OF LAW AND FACULTY
DIRECTOR OF THE ACADEMIC
INDIGENOUS LAWCENTER AT THE
COLLEGE. I'VE BEEN ON THE
FACULTY. FOR THIRTY ONE YEARS I
T. EACH PROPERTY AND VOTER
INDIAN. I ON THE LEGACY REVIEW
COMMITTEE FOR THREE I AM NOW TO
YEARS THE U. K. RESTORED OR JOE
OF BOARD. I A BEEN PARTY TO OF
RESTORATIVE CONVERSE IN BY AND
AFTER COLLEGE AND BY AND AT
MOUNT VALLEY- I CONTINUE TO
WHOLEHEARTEDLY CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AT
THE COLLEGE AND ACROSS THE STATE
. I'M READING THE SB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT IT DOES TWO THINGS
ONE IT REMOVES RAN AS HIS TEAM'S
NAME FROM THE COLLEGE STRONG
MAJORITY OF STAKEHOLDERS AGREED
THIS IS NECESSARY TO IT LOCATES
THE COLLEGE GEOGRAPHICALLY. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA APOLOGIZE FOR OVER A
CENTURY OF DEPREDATIONS AND
PREJUDICIAL POLICIES AGAINST
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS AND
ESTABLISHED A TRUTH AND HEALING
COMMISSION. IN LIGHT OF THAT
APOLOGY ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE
LAW SCHOOL WAS FOUNDED IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS A FAR MORE NEUTRAL
REFERENCE THAN RETAINING ANY
EARLY STATEHOOD AFTER HIS NAME
WOULD BE. ALONG THE SAME LINES I
FIND SB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
IMPLICITLY RESPECTFUL. OF THE
CURRENT PROTOCOL SURROUNDING
TRIBAL LANDED KNOWLEDGE MINTS
ACROSS THE STATE. ON THE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ISSUE I
BELIEVE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
SHOULD BE MORE THAN SYMBOLIC.
THE IDEA THAT LEGISLATION COULD
DECLARE A BENCHMARK FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN THE
ABSTRACT IS APPEALING. BUT ONLY
IF THE PROMISES MADE MADE WITHIN
ANY PIECE OF LEGISLATION CAN IN
FACT BE REALIZED IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE AFFECTED NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES. OTHERWISE
ANY LIST RISKS BECOMING JUST
ANOTHER SYMBOL. WHILE
LEGISLATION CAN BEGIN TO DEFINE
A BENCHMARK OF RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE SB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
DOES NOT TAKE THAT STEP IN THE
ABSTRACT YET THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD. IT
LEAVES THE DOOR OPEN FOR
MEANINGFUL PARTNERSHIP GOING
FORWARD TO DEFINE WHAT REAL
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE CONVENE IN A
PARTICULAR CONTEXT. FOR THESE
REASONS I SUPPORT S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT AND I THANK THE
SENATORS FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OR IT WILL COME HERE TO ROUTE
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YEAH COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DAVID FRIEDMAN- THE
CHANCE OF INDIAN AT UC HASTINGS
AND I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION- AND THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPEECH WILL BE EIGHTY EIGHTTHANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN THE ROOM SEEING NONE
MADAM MODERATOR WE WILL GO TO
YOU CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO STATE THEIR
NAME AND SUPPORT. FOR SB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. OF EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AT THE END. OF. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBERS.
NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT FIFTY
NINE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
CREW I'M A HASTINGS GRADUATE
CLASS OF EIGHTY ONE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JOHN CHAPEL A
GRADUATED FROM HASTINGS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU OXFORD. NINE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS DRONE
KANDEL CLASS OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT FROM HASTINGS THE FORMER
ALUMNI ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT NASCAR AND I
THOUGHT. NINE ONE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE GATHER THE NEXT
LINE NUMBER.
NINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS DEBORAH BOKHARI HI
AM. CLASS OF NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
IF YOU SEE HATING A LOT MY
DAUGHTER CAN HELP OKAY CLASSES
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN I AM
CURRENTLY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UC HASTINGS ORDER TRUSTEE. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. SB ONE TWO
EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND- THERE'S NO FURTHER LINES IN
Q. IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR ARE YOU WILL NOW GO TO
LEAD OPPOSITION- WE HAVE TWO
ALUMNI BELIEVE BOTH ARE HERE- TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
KRISTIN CHRIS WHITTEN AND WE
ALSO HAVE THE HONORABLE RICHARD
FLYER WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST
. ALL RIGHT PLEASE PROCEDURE OF
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU YOU MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS A CHRIS
WOULDN'T TAKE THIS THING OFF-
I'M A MEMBER OF THE CLASS OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AT
HASTINGS. AND BECAUSE OF THAT I
HAVE THE HONOR OF BEING- HAVING
A CAREER AS AN A DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- FROM WHICH I'M NOT
RETIRED. I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THE WHAT I HEARD THIS MORNING%
JUST NOW- BOUNCE AROUND THE
TASTINGS IS DIAMETRICALLY
OPPOSED TO WHAT I UNDERSTAND TO
BE THE TRUTH- THERE IS NO DIRECT
EVIDENCE THAT'S RIGHT AS
HASTINGS. HAD ANY INVOLVEMENT IN
ANY OF THE DASTARDLY ACTIONS.
AGAINST NATIVE AMERICANS DURING
MENTAL SCENE- INDIAN WARS AND
WHAT THEY'RE CALLED. ARE THEY
WERE WARS BUT HASTINGS DID NOT
START CONSPIRE IN FACILITY OR
SERVE IN THOSE WARS. IN FACT THE
ONLY DIRECT EVIDENCE OF WHETHER
HASTINGS WAS COMPLICIT IN THOSE
WARS IS HIS SWORN TESTIMONY
GIVEN IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY. IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S INVESTIGATION
WHICH DID NOT EVEN SEE THE LIGHT
OF DAY. IN THE WHITE PAPER THAT
THE- THE COLLEGE COMMISSION AND
FORM THE BASIS FOR THIS ATTEMPT
TO CHANGE THE NAME. WHAT
HASTINGS ACTUALLY DID. WAS USE
THE EXISTING LAWS TO PROTECT
HIMSELF AND OTHER SETTLERS FROM
THE VIOLENCE PERPETRATED ON THEM
BY NATIVE AMERICANS. NOW WHAT
WAS SAID EARLIER IS DEFINITELY
TRUE THIS WAS A STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SPONSORED- I
WANT TO CALL IT A PROGRAM TO
THAT'S THE WAY THINGS WERE DONE
AND SOMEBODY. UP EARLIER TODAY
OF REFERRED TO BRINGING AMERICA
WEST WELL THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU BRING AMERICA WEST
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS
STATE- THE SETTLERS MALICIOUS
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE CALLED
IN THE STATUTES THAT THAT OF
FORMED THEM THE- THEY THEY WERE
APPOINTED AND SUPERVISED BY THE
GOVERNOR IN ORDER TO. ENFORCE%
THE LAW AND THEY GOT OUT OF HAND
I DON'T I DON'T QUESTION AT ALL
THE AWFUL AND I AND I WANT TO I
WANT TO SAY I'M 2100% IN IN
FAVOR OF WHAT BEING FIGMENT IS
DOING WITH RESTORATIVE JUSTICE I
HAVE BEEN FROM THE START AND
I'VE BEEN YOU KNOW- I'D LIKE TO
THINK YOUR TWO MINUTES OF
INCORRECT OKAY OKAY- I JUST WANT
ALSO STRESSED THAT THE STATE AND
FEDERAL CONSTITUTIONS. IN MY
VIEW- PROHIBIT THE REMOVAL OF
THE NAME BECAUSE THE CONTRACT
WAS ENTERED INTO BETWEEN
HASTINGS AND THE STATE AND THERE
ARE CONTRACT CLAUSES AND EACH
CONSTITUTION AND THERE'S THE OF
APPLES ARE YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
NEXT WITNESS HONORABLE RICHARD
FLYER YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AS
WELL. GOOD MORNING MILNOR EAGER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WRONGLY ACCUSED JUSTICE HASTINGS
WAS NOT GUILTY OF ANY HORRENDOUS
ACCIDENTS NATIVE CALIFORNIANS
THE LEGISLATIVE INVESTIGATION
YOUR LEGISLATIVE INVESTIGATION
CONFIRMED THAT. HE WAS A SETTLER
WHO LEGALLY BOUGHT LAND FROM
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WHEN US
ARMY REFUSED TO PROTECT HIS
PROPERTY HE PETITIONED THE
GOVERNOR ALONG WITH OTHER
SETTLERS TO HAVE THE GOVERNOR
SET UP A MILITIA WHICH WAS
AUTHORIZED BY LAW IN THE MILITIA
IS THE ONE THAT THAT THE WORST
WAS. INVITED WITH IT THE ABILITY
TO CARRY OUT THE GOVERNOR'S
INSTRUCTIONS. HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF LAW IS AN INSTITUTION. THE
OLDEST PUBLIC LAWSUIT LAW SCHOOL
IN THE STATE. LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF LAWYERS JUDGES
POLITICAL LEADERS HAVE
MATRICULATED AT THIS SCHOOL. I
DOUBT WHETHER A MAJORITY OF THEM
EVEN KNOW WHO HASTINGS WAS. BUT
THEY KNOW WHO WHAT HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF LAW IS THERE SCHOOL
IT'S OUR IDENTITY. YOU AND I MAY
DIFFER ABOUT SERENA'S HASTINGS
THE FACTS ARE CLEAR HE IS
INNOCENT OF ANY WRONGDOING.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW IS NOT HARMED
A SINGLE NOT HARM A SINGLE
NATIVE AMERICAN IN ITS ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR YEAR HISTORY
. THE PROPOSAL IS LEGISLATION IS
ILLEGAL YOUR LEGISLATION AS WELL
AS AB NINETEEN THIRTY SIX.
JUSTICE HASTINGS AND- ENTERED
INTO AN AGREEMENT THEY DON'T
CALL THE AGREEMENT IT'S AN
AGREEMENT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS DONATED TO ESTABLISH A
PUBLIC LAW SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
HASTINGS DESCENDANT ALWAYS HAD
TO BE ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
AND THAT'S CONTINUED FOR A
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR YEARS. THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS WAS
INDEPENDENT OF THE BOARD OF
REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE SCHOOL WOULD
FOREVER BE KNOWN AS HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW. IF YOU
DIDN'T HEAR THAT LET ME REPEAT
IT FOR EVER KNOWN AS THE
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW YOUR TWO
MINUTES PLEASE REFEREE GOOD IN
EVERY TIME ANY GOVERNMENT OR
PERSON HAS TRIED TO CHANGE THESE
CONTRACT TERMS. CALIFORNIA
COURTS HAVE STRUCK IT DOWN. THIS
WAS NO ACCIDENT. HE'S BEING THAT
YOU ARE AT YOUR IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL DOESN'T MATTER. ALL
RIGHT MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY WITH THEIR
NAME AND OPPOSITION TO S. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT BUT WE
GATHER THE LINE NUMBERS.
NINE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS A BRAND VERNE CLASS OF-
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN SINGS
CULTURE LAW AND I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MADAM SHARE
MY NAME IS DONALD MITCHELL I AM
A GRADUATE OF HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF THE LAW LAST. GUY EMAIL DO
YOU WANT OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE A LETTER EXPRESSING MY
OPPOSITION OF MY ATTACHED THANK
YOU SIR WE SHOULD NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DEV HIDE AND I'M FROM
THE UK CRIED ARAMBULA TRIP IN
INDIAN RESERVATIONS I'M OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL- TRY IT DID A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE HAS NOT BEEN
DONE IF WE'RE NOT BOTH SITTING
AT THE TABLE AND THANK YOU MA'AM
I WAS CALLING PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
ALRIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION
COMMENTS DEBATE CENTERED ALWAYS
SEND REQUIRE- THAN CENTER PAN
CENTER CORTESE. EVERYONE
THOROUGHLY WILL START WITH YOU.
THANK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT TO. WHAT'S
THE PROBLEM I BELIEVE THAT.
THERE WAS A MESSAGE NINETY EIGHT
HERE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE. YOU
TO MY OPPOSITION YOU CAN GET UP
AND STATE YOUR NAME IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL YES.
THANK YOU SCOTT MY NAME IS
WINNER MOTO ANDERSON I REPRESENT
AROUND RALLY. INDIAN TRIBES YOU
CAN CHARGE. AND WE CAN STUDY AND
STUDY AND DO RESEARCH PAPERS
THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PAY OFF AND YES I'M OPPOSE.
THANK ONLY THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE
I MISSED YOU EARLIER SIR. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JAMES RESTS
ON THE DELAY LIKE TO PRESIDENT
ROUND ON THE INDIAN TRIBES AND
I'D LIKE TO JUST EXPRESS MY-
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
BUT I'D LIKE TO BE CLEAR ON WHAT
WHAT THE TRIBAL COUNCIL- IS
OPPOSING AND SO WHAT I
APPRECIATE THAT SIR BUT WE HAD
OUR LEAD OPPOSITION JUST LIKE WE
HAD OUR LEAD SUPPORT AND THEN WE
GET TO THE POINT WHERE YOU CAN
STATE YOUR NAME AND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SO WE
WERE REQUIRED TO AS OPPOSING THE
BILL IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEND
SOMETHING TO THE COMMITTEE SO
THAT WE CAN PUT IN THE RECORD
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO DO THAT
THERE WAS A LETTER SENT
YESTERDAY AND WE HAVE IT THE
MANAGER OF ONE OF I GUESS ORDER
QUESTION. WOULD BEAPPROPRIATE
IN OUR COMMENTARY TO ASK
QUESTIONS FOR EXAMPLEOF THE
TRIBAL LEADERS ABSOLUTELY THE
WILL THAT THAT'S AN OPTION AS A
AS A COMMITTEE MEMBER HE WAS
CERTAINLY MAY DO THAT THANK SOME
I'M TRYING TO KEEP THE DECORUM
OF THE- OF THE COMMITTEE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I. FIRST WANTED TO SAY
THAT. I KNOW YOU YOU HAVE A
TOUGH JOB OF TRYING TO- GET
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT THE SAME
TIME. YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
SENATORS ARE SITTING HERE MAKING
DECISIONS AS OF LAST NIGHT I WAS
LOBBIED OR BROUGHT INFORMATION
ON THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WHICH IS. A BIG DEAL THIS IS A
BIG DEAL WE HAVE THREE SENATORS.
HERE MANY AS MUCH TIME AS THEY
WANT- TO EXPLAIN THEIR SIDE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND WE HAVE
OPPOSITION. WHO GETS TWO MINUTES
AND I THINK THAT I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE TO RUN MEETINGS BUT IT'S
NOT FAIR TO EVEN US AS- AS
LEGISLATORS WHO ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. WHAT HAPPENED A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YEAR HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR YEARS AGO. AND WHAT
WAS WRONG AND HOW WE'RE GONNA
MAKE IT RIGHT AND THOSE ARE
TOUGH DECISIONS. AND THE
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE. IMPACT
NATIVE AMERICANS IMPACT. PEOPLE
WHO WENT TO THEIR SCHOOL AND I
REPRESENT. ELEVEN COUNTIES AND I
HAVE VERY. A DIVERSE AMOUNT OF
NATIVE AMERICANS WHO WERE
WRONGED. I WASN'T THERE WHEN
THEY WERE WRONG BUT THEY WERE
WRONG IN THEIR HISTORY- IT. IS
REALLY SAD FOR OUR STATE AND FOR
OUR NATION BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ARE GOING TO GO
INTO THE FUTURE ON THINGS THAT
HAPPENED IN THE PAST AND MANY
THINGS HAVE HAPPENED OVER THESE
LONG PERIODS OF TIME. AND SO
THERE'S A BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY
THERE'S A LOT MOVING IN THIS
AREA OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THIS NAMING OF THE SCHOOL. I'M
NOT GONNA VOTE FOR THE BILL
TODAY ON A LAYOFF THE BILL
BECAUSE I THINK THERE NEEDS TO
BE QUITE FRANKLY A LOT MORE
DISCUSSION A LOT MORE-
INFORMATION BROUGHT FORWARD BUT
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I THINK
THE PROCESS. THAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH IS UNFORTUNATELY WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY HERE ALL
ALL ALL THE TESTIMONY. AND GET
ALL THE FACTS- BROCK ROB FORD.
THIS BILL IMPACTS. THE SENATOR
FROM THE SECOND DISTRICT AS
WELL. WHO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING HIS CAUGHT A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT SO- WE'RE
GONNA MAKE A DECISION ON
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED.
LITERALLY OVER A HUNDRED AND
FORTY YEARS AGO AND WE WERE IN
THERE AND THE FACTS NEED TO BE.
VERY CLEARED SO WE CAN MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS THAT'S WHAT I WANNA
SAY TODAY SO I THINK IT'S
PREMATURE AND MOVING THE BILL
FORWARD QUITE RIGHT. UNTIL WE
HAVE THOSE FACTS. THANK YOU SIR
AT ALL AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THIS IS OUR PROCESS AND IF THE
IF YOU WANT TO CHANGE PROCESS WE
NEED TO TAKE THAT UP WITH THE
RULES COMMITTEE. SAN REQUIRE
YOU'RE UP NEXT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. VENTURE INTO A WANNA SAY.
HOW GRATEFUL I AM- BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS HEARING THANK YOU TO
THE- THREE LEADERS HERE IN THE
SENATE FOCUS ON THE STEINORTH.
THANK YOU. RIGHT TO PRESENT RUSS
IN THE MEMBERS. OF ARAMBULA
INDIAN TRIBES AS WELL AS YOU CAN
PEOPLE HERE TODAY. WHEN I JUST
ADDRESS- THE ISSUE IS IF THIS IS
FAKE NEWS OR NOT. I THINK IN A
HUNDRED YEARS WE'RE GONNA LOOK
BACK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
UKRAINE THERE WILL BE SOME FOLKS
IT WILL SAY- THERE WASN'T A
MASSACRE. IN UKRAINE. IT'S EASY
TO DO A CENTURY LATER. BUT THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE WRONGED ARE
SITTING IN THIS HEARING ROOM
RIGHT NOW THANK BE REALLY CANDID
IT IS EMBARRASSING TO HEAR FOLKS
COME IN AND TRY TO DEFEND THE
NAME. OF THIS INSTITUTION. IT'S
REALLY UPSETTING TO ME. IT'S
EASY FOR US TO OUR ANGLO
AMERICANS TO STAND UP AND SPEAK
ABOUT THE SO CALLED INNOCENCE OF
MISTER HASTINGS LEVINE INNOCENT
ABOUT IT THIS NAME CHANGE SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED YEARS AGO. AND I
THINK WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE
FACTS HERE TODAY AND THE FACTS
ARE. BOTH THE YOU KEEP PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE OF AROUND L. INDIAN
TRIBES. THEY WERE MASSACRED
LET'S CALL IT WHAT IT IS-
GENOCIDE. AND WE SIT HERE EVERY
NIGHT LOOKING AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING UKRAINE AND THERE'S
GENOCIDE HAPPENING THERE AND
THAT HAPPENED IN THE STATE. I
HAVE BEEN HERE STATE AND WAS.
OUR GOVERNMENT THAT DID IT. SO
NOW WE'RE CENTURY LATER WE'RE
GONNA SAY IT WASN'T HIM BUT IT
WAS ACTUALLY THE STATE THAT
ALLOWED. I'M SORRY I JUST CANNOT
BELIEVE THAT INDIVIDUALS WOULD
COME UP AND SUPPORT THAT. VIEW
KANDYANS WERE MASSACRED. AND I
AGREE THAT THE HASTINGS NAME
SHOULD FOREVER BE STRIPPED FROM
THE BUILDING. SCOURGE ON OUR
HISTORY. BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE
FIRST. ARE IN THE PEOPLE OF THE
ROUND ALLEY INDIAN TRIBES IN THE
U. K. PEOPLE DESERVE BETTER FROM
THE STATE. SO DO ALL THE OTHER
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE WEST.
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE COME TO
TERMSTHE ONLY WAY THAT WE COME
TO TERMS WITH THE ATROCITIES OF
THE PAST IS BY SHAPING A
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR THE NATIVE
PEOPLE IN THE STATE IN THE
FUTURE. THERE IS A REASON WHY
NATIVE CHILDREN HAVE THE HIGHEST
ACES SCORES IN THE STATE. WHY
SOME OF THE HIGHEST POVERTY
RATES IN THE STATE PER CAPITA
EXIST ON NATIVE AMERICAN
RESERVATIONS. WHY THERE IS MORE
FIT NO USE IN DRUG USE AND
ALCOHOL USE WITHIN THE TRIBES OF
CALIFORNIANS COMMUNITY IT IS
BECAUSE IT IS BECAUSE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO THIS PAST IN THE
PAST. WITH THESE PEOPLE. SO
HERE'S MY BOTTOM LINE IN THIS
LEGISLATION. I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH WHERE CENTER AMBERG IN
CENTER WIENER AND A MAJORITY
LEADER EMERITUS HERTZBERG WANT
TO GO ON THIS AND I SUPPORT IT.
BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT TO LOSE
SIGHT ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO WE
NEED TO FOCUS IN ON. THIS IS
MUCH MORE THAN A NAME CHANGE.
THIS IS ABOUT LIFTING UP THE
PEOPLE OF AROUND ALLEY INDIAN
TRIBES IN THE U. K. PEOPLE. THIS
LEGISLATION MUST BE SPECIFIC
ABOUT THE PROGRAMS SERVICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT IT WILL
PROVIDE. FOR THOSE NATIVE
RESIDENTS. I'M SORRY- MANAGER I
DON'T USUALLY GET HOT AROUND THE
COLLAR- BUT IT IS VERY PERSONAL
FOR ME AND I SEE DAY IN AND DAY
OUT WERE PRESENT RUSS IS
FOCUSING ON HIS TRIED AND HOW
HE'S TRYING. TO WORK FOR A
BETTER LIFE FOR HIS FOLKS AND IF
IT'S ALRIGHT TO THE CHAIR I JUST
LIKE TO ASK PRESENT REST A FEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE RIGHT
MANAGER ABSOLUTELY YOUR
DISCRETION. MMHM THE REST AS YOU
COME UP A QUESTION THAT I HAVE.
IS IN YOUR FULL DISCLOSURE THE
PRESENT I HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS. BUT I THINK THAT
WHERE YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO GO
WITH HIS LEGISLATION ALSO KNOWN
AS ASSEMBLY BILL. MOVING FORWARD
BUT IT'S ABOUT PROGRAMS IT'S
ABOUT SERVICES. IT'S ABOUT
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
FUTURE IT'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE. OF
THE TRIBE PLEASE I DON'T WANT TO
PUT WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH- YES SIR
THAT'S WHAT I WAS IN AND JUST.
TAKE A MOMENT TO EXPLAIN ALL
AGO. WAS THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
SOME VERY GOOD DISCUSSIONS. I A
WITH THEM IN FACT WHEN I REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO THANK HIM AND HIS
STAFF. AND ALL THE ALL THE FOLKS
THAT ARE INVOLVED. AND SO WE'VE
BEEN HAVING SOME GOOD
DISCUSSIONS ON WHAT WE'RE
CALLING THE INITIATIVES FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. AND THOSE
OF A VERY FRUITFUL DISCUSSIONS
WE HAVE ONE ANOTHER ONE PLANNED
THIS AFTERNOON. TO COME TO THE
TABLE AND DISCUSS THESE ISSUES.
SO I THINK THAT ARE UP MARK ARE
OPPOSITION AS THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL. TO THE BILL WAS THAT
THAT WASN'T INCLUDED. BUT THEN
WE JUST HEAR THESE GENTLEMEN
THAT HAVE COLLECTED THE BILL
THIS MORNING- TESTIFYING THAT
THE ANOTHER. FOR ALL INTENTS AND
PURPOSES THEY WANT TO INCLUDE
THOSE. RESTORATIVE JUSTICE YOU.
SO I TOTALLY SUPPORT THAT. AND
THEY WANT TO SIT DOWN AT THE
TABLE WITH US AND WE'RE MORE
THAN WILLING TO DO THAT. SO I
THINK WE COULD BE MOVED FORWARD
IN A POSITIVE MANNER AND WE
COULD HAVE SOME FRUITFUL
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS. I CAN SEE
THAT HAPPENING ALREADY. NO I
THINK YOU SO MUCH. MISTER
PRESIDENT I THINK THAT-
INVOLVING- MISTER AMBERG MISTER
WIENER IN MISTER HERTZBERG ALONG
WITH MISTER AHMOSE IS GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
CORRECT. I AGREE. HUH 100% IN
MISTER PRESIDENT ANY OTHER ITEM
THAT YOU. I MAY NEGLECT TO-
MENTION YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE OUT
OF. WITH I JUST WANTED TO REALLY
REACH OUT TO- AND MENTION THAT-
THE ASTINGS- STAFF HAS BEEN FOR
A FRUITFUL AND VERY FORWARD
INCOMING WITH THESE ISSUES. TO
THE TRIED THEY'VE BEEN AROUND
VALLEY WE'VE TALKED TO THEM
THEY'VE INVITED THE YOU
COMMITTEE DONNA SUMMER CISCO.
NOW WITH THEM LATER THAN BY THE
TRIBAL COUNCIL TO COME DOWN. SO
WE HAVE HAD SOME GOOD
DISCUSSIONS AND THEY'VE BEEN
FOOT VERY FORWARD INCOMING WITH
THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ISSUES.
AND IDENTIFYING THOSE ISSUES
WITH US AND NOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE JUST GOING THROUGH A
KIND OF- REFINING THOSE ISSUES
AND- MAKING THEM SO THAT THEIR-
DOABLE. AND THAT WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT ON THEM SO I THINK THE
PROCESS HAS STARTED WITH- AND I
WITH. SOMEONE RAMOS BUT I THINK
IT'LL CONTINUE WITH THE
GENTLEMAN WITH THIS BILL. I
THINK IT'S MUCH SIMPLER BUT I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE AMENDMENTS
TO BE PUT TO THIS BILL THAT'S
WHAT WE POST WAS THAT THE THOSE
WERE INCLUDED IN THERE. IN THE
FIRST PLACE. BUT I THINK WE'RE
ALL IN AGREEMENT ON STRIKING OF
THE NAME. SO A HUNDRED PERCENT.
VERY GOOD. I THINK IN A FINISH
UP AND JUST SAY AGAIN IS PRESENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH- AND TO ALL
WHO TRAVELED. FAR AND WIDE TO BE
ABLE TO BE HERE IN THE CAPITAL
TODAY VERY GRATEFUL. NOW SOMEONE
AYE AYE TAKE MOM TO BE ABLE TO
KNOWLEDGE CENTER NUMBERS AND
WIENER ANSWER HERTZBERG FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO THIS TRULY-
INSURER FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
BE ABL TO. ENGAGE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT ABLE TO GET THIS
DONE- AND I KNOW THAT YOU ARE
HERE TODAY AND YOU HAVE ALREADY
SAID YOU'RE COMMITTED TO THAT I
LOOK FOR TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY HOW GRATEFUL I AM FOR AT
THIS EFFORT. AND MANAGER I
APPRECIATE THE POINT PERSON FOR
THE G. PROVIDING TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE
AND I MISTER PRESIDENT I ALSO
JUST WANTED TO SAY. I WAS VERY
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT THE- AUTHORS
OF THE BILL ARE GONNA BE WORKING
ON RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT WAS NOT
FORMALLY INCLUDED IN THE BILL
SO. BEEN A POSITIVE DAY SO FAR.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
CENTER GLAZER. THANK YOU A MAN
ZERO I APPRECIATE. CENTER
MAGUIRE'S ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
PRESIDENT TO HAVE FROM AROUND
VALLEY I WAS GOING TO ALSO. HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS I THINK THEY WERE
COVERED BY THAT I WANT TO GIVEN
pIN OUR HEARING TODAY. I'M I'M
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THESE. TYPES
OF DISCUSSIONS- AT THE FIRST
BILL THAT I INTRODUCED IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. WAS A BILL TO REMOVE
THE NAME OF CONFEDERATE LEADERS
FROM OUR PUBLIC BUILDINGS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA- FOR THE SAME
REASONS THAT I THINK THIS.
DEBATE AND DISCUSSIONS ARE. ARE
CONTINUING BECAUSE THE- YOU KNOW
WE WANT THERE TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR PEOPLE. AND
WE WANT- NAMES TO REFLECT PLACES
OF HONOR. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE AUTHORS ARE TRYING TO
ADVANCE WITH THIS BILL I AM. AND
THEN BY THE WAY BECAUSE IT WAS
REFERENCE TO THE STATE
SANCTIONING OF THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY ABSOLUTE THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY WHAT'S- AND- OUR
FIRST GOVERNOR GOVERNOR BURNETT
- MADE STATEMENTS AND WAS
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN AN
EXTERMINATION ACTIVITIES IN OUR
STATE. FIRST GOVERNOR AND- IF
YOU GO TO THE CAPITOL TODAY. YOU
WILL SEE HIS PORTRAIT IN A PLACE
OF HONOR. AND I WOULD CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE- A REVIEW OF THAT-
SITUATION. I HAD MINIMUM- BUT I
AT MATTERS LIKE THIS I DEFER TO
THE COLLEGE I THINK THEY'VE GOT
ENGAGED IN A THOUGHTFUL PROCESS.
TO COME TO GRIPS WITH THAT THE
HISTORY AND ALL OF THAT I THINK
THAT THE BILL TODAY DOESN'T
SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS WOULD
CERTAINLY ELIMINATE SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS CLEARLY- IT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. AND I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT I THINK THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY IS A HEALTHY
THING IT TAKES A LOT OF
COMMITTEE TIME AND ALL THE REST
BUT I ENCOURAGE IT IN EVERY
LEVEL OF PUBLIC LIFE THAT- THAT
YOUR HISTORY WILL BE REVIEWED
IT'S NOT. A ONE TIME THING WHEN
YOU'RE POPULAR AND ALL AND ALL
THAT AND I HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE
TO DO THAT KIND OF EXAMINATION.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER CENTER
PAM. THANK YOU AND I OF WANT
JUST APPRECIATE THE- REMARKS AND
QUESTIONS OF MUCH OF THE SENATE
MCGUIRE AND THE CENTER OF
GLACIER- YEAH I HEARD THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHORS TO
WORK WITH THE TRIBES AND
ADDRESSING THOSE PARTICULAR
ISSUES- AND- SO THAT'S MY HOPE
TO SEE HAPPEN- AS- THE BILL
MOVES ALONG AND FORGET TO THE
FLOOR- SO WITH THAT- I. WILL BE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND THE
WILL MOVE THE BILL APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
CENTER CORTESE. HEY JUST OVER
KIND OF A TECHNICAL QUESTION AND
I'M- OF A LIMIT MISSY
EXPLANATION SOMEHOW IN THE
PRESENTATION BUT- IN STRIKING.
HE SEEMS AND LEAVING COLLEGE OF
THE LAW- IT SEEMS LIKE COLUSA
SUPPORT THE BILL WERE NOT TO BE
FURTHER AMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S WALKING INTO THAT
. PARTICULAR NAME COLLEGE OF THE
LAW I UNDERSTAND OF COURSE
EVERYTHING ELSE HE SAID ABOUT-
YOU SEE IN THE BOARD AND OTHER
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
DISCUSSION AND I JUST HEARD THE
TESTIMONY. DOES UP WITH THAT
THEN WE- IS THE PRESUMPTION THAT
THAT THAT'LL BE OF FURTHER NAME
CHANGE AMENDED IN OR THAT THIS
NAME CAN STAY THE WAY IT IS
WITHOUT IMPACTING- WOULD YOU SEE
WILL LATER RECOMMEND. SO A
COUPLE THANK YOU FOR RAISING THE
QUESTION NUMBER NUMBER ONE
NUMBER NUMBER TWO IS THAT- BY
STRIKING NAME HASTINGS. THE
LIKELY DEFAULT POSITION WOULD BE
UC COLLEGE OF LAW UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF LAW WE
REALIZE THAT THAT IT DOESN'T
COMPLETELY NAME THE SCHOOL AND
THAT WILL BE OF FURTHER
PROBABLY. A DENOMINATION
INSERTING NAMED ST LOUIS THIS IS
MY THOUGHT NAZARIAN NAME SAN
FRANCISCO OMEWHERE IN THAT
COLLECTION OF WORDS- BUT IT'S
NOT FINALIZED YET. HELLO AS- I
WILL THERE ARE- AS THERE ALWAYS
IS WITH ANYTHING YOU SEE-
THERE'S SORT OF AN ODDITY HERE
THAT THE LOGIC DOESN'T. YOU SEE
IS CONSTITUTIONALLY SEMI
AUTONOMOUS AND WITH TYPICALLY
NAME ITSELF- BUT THIS IS A
HUNDRED FIFTY YEAR OLD STATUTE
ANSWER UC HASTINGS HAS BEEN. IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE RETURNS
WITH THE UC R. P.TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE IS ON THE SAME PAGE
WITH UCSF- AND SO- THAT OUR
MEDICAL SCHOOL- AND SO- YEAH AND
BUT IT'LL BE. A BROADER CONVERT
CONVERSATION. THROUGH CHARMING
THING I'M ASKING THIS AND I
THINK THIS GOES TO THE LAST
OPPOSITION THAT WE HEARD.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL TODAY AS IT
MOVES OUT OF COMMITTEE
PREJUDICES THE FOR THE- NAMING
OF THE SCHOOL THAT'S CORRECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE UP BEFORE WE GO TO YOUR
CLOSE I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
BEFORE US TODAY. AS A
DISASSOCIATE SERRANO'S HASTINGS
FROM CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PUBLIC
LAW COLLEGE THE BILL'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS DECISION TO CALL INTO
QUESTION THE LEGACY OF THE
COLLEGE'S NAME SAKE BASED ON
HASTINGS. INVOLVEMENT IN THE-MASS KILLINGS OF NATIVE
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA'S EVEN
AND RAN BALLETS IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES IT MATTERS VERY MUCH IT
MATTERS WHO PUBLIC COLLEGES
HONOR IT IS A STATEMENT OF AN
INSTITUTION'S VALUES. AND BY
EXTENSION THAT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RENAMING HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF LAW IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO IN PARTICULAR FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS FACULTY
AND COMMUNITY. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
COMPETING OPINIONS ABOUT WHAT
THE NEW NAME SHOULD BE AND WHAT
THE NEW RENAMING PROCESS SHOULD
INVOLVE. MOVING FORWARD I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ALL AUTHORS
OF THE BILL TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH COLLEGE LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS WHO INTRODUCED A
BILL ON THE SAME SUBJECT. AND
THE ROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBAL
COUNCIL AND YOU KEY INDIAN
COMMITTEE ON THE APPROPRIATE
NEXT STEPS FOR RENAMING THE
COLLEGE WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LIVE LET
ME BEGIN BY THANKING PRESIDENT
RUSS- PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF
THE ATROCITIES COMMITTED UPON
HIS PEOPLE THAT DOUBT WE MET
WITH HIM THE THREE OF US MET
WITH HIM IN HIS- OPEN HEART AND
OPEN MIND. WITH RESPECT TO HOW
WE CAN WILL NEVER GOING TO RIGHT
THIS WRONG WE'RE NEVER GOING TO
RIGHT THIS WRONG BUT BUT HOW WE
CAN. BATES BASICALLY MAKE SURE
THAT. ONE THE PEOPLE ARE
EDUCATED TO THAT WE DO WHAT WHAT
WE CAN TO PROVIDE SOME-
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR THOSE
WHO WERE THE ANCESTORS. OF OF
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN AFFLICTED I
WANT ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
WITH CENTER MCGUIRE THANK YOU
SENATE MCGUIRE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- AND
THEN A COUPLE RESPONSES ONE. ONE
OF THE FOLKS OPPOSITION AS YOU
CAN SEE THIS IS NOT. A UNIVERSAL
OPINION THE NAME HE'S THING
SHOULD COME OFF IT IS OUR VIEW
ARE VERY STRONG VIEW- THAT IT
SHOULD COME OFF BUT AGAIN. NOT
UNANIMOUS. OF. EDUCATION FOUND
THAT HASTINGS WAS NOT INVOLVED
THESE ATROCITIES. THAT IS TRUE
THAT WAS INVESTIGATION IS DONE
EIGHTEEN SIXTY AND IS A FURTHER
EMBARRASSMENT TO US. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ABSOLVE HIM
WHERE THE HISTORIC RECORD IS I
THINK COMPLETE AND REPLETE. WITH
THE EVIDENCE OF HASTINGS
PARTICIPATION THESE ATROCITIES-
SECONDLY IN TERMS OF THE
HASTINGS DESCENDANTS I'M
INFORMED THAT COLONEL CLAUS.
LEYVA HELP WHO IS THE DESCENDANT
OF SERENA'S HASTINGS WHO DOES
SIT ON THE BOARD. SUPPORTS THE
REMOVAL OF THE NAME HASTINGS.
AND THUS TO THE EXTENT THAT
ANYBODY HAS ANY EQUITY IN THAT
NAME. THIS PERSON COLONEL LEHMAN
HOW HIS AGREED THAT NAME SHOULD
COME OFF AND WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I WANT TO
THANK THE JOINT AUTHORS THERE'S
ACTUALLY BEEN A LOT OF EFFORT
PUT IN THIS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO ADDITIONAL EFFORT BEING PUT
AN- ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
I'M BURKE THANK YOU FOR THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN. MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI. LEYVA
OHIO TO A VOTE. THE TROUBLED BY
PARTISI. PRETEND THE I. DALI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN. ALL
RIGHT. HI THANK YOU GENTLEMEN
THAT BILL IS OUT TO YOUR- ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE SEVEN SENATOR
CORTEZ. PRISON SB. THIRTY FORTY
ONE. BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
SENATOR. OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS TODAY I'M
HERE 2% SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE OF
THE CALIFORNIA SORE AS IN S. O.
A. R. GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAM
. OXLEY TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS. WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S K. TWELVE SCHOOL
SYSTEM ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS RIGHT RIGHT NOW- OF
THAT NUMBER A NUMBER THAT HAS
INCREASED BY OVER 40% THE PAST
DECADE ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND.
OUR CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS BY UTILIZING FUNDS FROM
THE MCKINNEY VENTO ACT A KEY
FEDERAL LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THE ACT WAS
INTENDED TO BE A FIRST STEP
TOWARD RESOLVING HOMELESSNESS.
HOWEVER IN THE ABSENCE OF
LEGISLATION. BUT CONTINUING TO
FURTHER UP MEASURES FOR REACHING
MEASURES HOMELESSNESS CAN ONLY
BE EXPECTED TO INCREASE AMONGST
THIS POPULATION. THE LAW ONLY
APPLIES TO CURRENTLY ENROLLED
STUDENTS MEANING A STUDENT%
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WILL
ONLY RECEIVE SUPPORT UP UNTIL
THEY GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
THE LACK OF SUPPORT AVAILABLE TO
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
POST GRADUATION SIGNIFICANTLY
HINDERS OUR ABILITY TO PURSUE
THEIR EDUCATION OR CAREER
AMBITIONS. WELL FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW PROVIDE EXTENSIVE
FINANCIAL AID TO YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHO
INTEND TO ENROLL IN COLLEGE THAT
HE DOES NOT BECOME AVAILABLE
UNTIL THE STUDENT BEGINS
ATTENDING COLLEGE IN THE FALL.
AS A RESULT MANY OF THESE YOU'VE
BECOME SUBJECT TO A PHENOMENA
KNOWN AS SUMMER MELT. THE
SCENARIO WHICH THE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE. IS ACCEPTED INTO
COLLEGE INTENDS TO ENROLL IT'LL
COMMITTEE DOES NOT. THIS PROBLEM
IS COMMON AMONG LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WHO LACK THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO MAKE THE TRANSITION
FROM HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE IN
THE FALL. THESE STUDENTS OFTEN
BECOME STICKER SHOCK. WHEN THEY
LEARNED. OF THE FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH TEN COLLEGE- IN THAT THEY
MUST BE PAID BEFORE THE THEIR
FINANCIAL AID KICKS IN. SUCH AS
THEIR SUMMER ORIENTATION FEE
HOUSING DEPOSIT PARKING PASS AND
SO ON IN RECOGNITION OF THE NEED
TO EXTEND SUPPORT TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS DURING THE
BRIDGE BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION AND POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. OR EMPLOYMENT SB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE ESTABLISHES A
STATEWIDE GUARANTEED INCOME
PROGRAM THAT WILL PROVIDE DIRECT
CASH ASSISTANCE ON A MONTHLY
BASIS TO THESE YOUTH. THE BILL
DEFINES INDULGENT A ELIGIBLE
PARTICIPANT UP FIRST AS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ENROLLED IN
THE TWELFTH GRADE SECONDLY
MISTER DEFINITION OF
HOMELESSNESS ACCORDING TO THE
MCCAIN OF ANTI ACT. IN THIRD OF
WAS COMPLETED A FAST SO OR
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT APPLICATION
AS PART OF IN ROMAN. THE PROGRAM
WILL SERVE APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS STATEWIDE BEGINNING
ON APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TREE THROUGH AUGUST FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO FIVE.
PAYMENTS ARE CONTEMPLATED THE
BILL DIRECTS THE ADMINISTRATOR
CAN TO CONDUCT AN EVALUATION OF
THE PROGRAM TO LEARN. HOW THIS
FORMA SUPPORT MAY ASSIST YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
EXITING THE CYCLE CYCLE OF
PROPERTY AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS.
ABOUT THE BILL- IS IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISRUPT THE CYCLE
OF HOMELESSNESS- IN REGENERATE-
AT THIS GREAT AT THIS AGE AT THE
TWELFTH GRADE. OF THE NO STRINGS
ATTACHED GUARANTEED INCOME MODEL
EMPOWER THESE USED TO USE THE
FUNDS AS THEY SEE FIT. WHETHER
THAT BE ENTERING INTO THE WORK
FORCE ULTIMATELY ARE PURSUING
HIGHER EDUCATION. SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE WILL EQUIP YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
EMBARK ON A PATH. TOWARD
STABILITY AND SUCCESS. I'D LIKE
TO THINK THAT YOU'RE IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING. WITH ME
AND MY STAFF ON THIS BILL. I
DON'T WHICH THAT WE DO NOT YET
HAVE AN ADMINISTRATOR NAME FOR
THE PROGRAM A COMMITTEE WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR. A TO DETERMINE
WHO WOULD BE THE BEST FIT. OF IN
PAST RECENT INVESTMENTS BY THIS
LEGISLATURE IN- A GENERAL- IN
GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAMS. A
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES WAS
DETERMINED TO BE THE RIGHT FIT-
IN DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD.
INTERNALLY AND WITH COLLEAGUES
WERE NOT CLEAR- THAT THAT'S THE
BEST FIT FOR THIS PROGRAM. BUT
THERE ARE OPTIONS WITH THAT SAID
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE YOU
HAVE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
BOTH HAVE CALLED IN WE HAVE
CRISTINA TORRES YOU'VE ADVOCATE
FROM THE JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOUTH. AND DR SCOTT MYERS
LIPTON A PROFESSOR AT SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO MISS TAURUS FIRST MISS
TAURUS YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU CAME AND THANK YOU
SENATOR. WORKING FOR ADVOCATING
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS BECAUSE-
WE'RE WORKING. I MYSELF WAS A
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL IN MY FOURTH
GRADE I AM A FORMER. NEWS AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE COOPER IN
KHARKIV BECAUSE- IT ALLOWS YOU
TO CONCENTRATE ON THEIR SCHOOL.
STRIVING. CONCENTRATING ON.
TRYING TO FIND WHERE THEY'RE TO
STAY WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO EAT
MY CELL HAD TO WITH THAT
HONESTLY FOR IMPORTANT TO ME AT
THE TIME BECAUSE I HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE I WAS GOING TO
EAT WELL THANKFULLY BUT ON TOP
OF THAT AS WELL I ALSO HAD A
DAUGHTER Q. SO YOU. IT WAS EVEN
MORE INSTRUCTIONS TO CONTINUE
TRYING TO GO TO SCHOOL BUT WHAT
THIS DOES NOT ALLOW A WHOLE
BURDEN TO COME OFF OF THE USE.
THAT IS HOMELESS AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO AND HOW TO
DO IT BUT WHAT THEY AND I'M SO
GRATEFUL THAT THIS HAS COME INTO
PLAY BECAUSE IT ALLOWS ARE YOU.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE WILL BE
THROUGH THEIR EDUCATION AND BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD RATHER THAN
STAYING AT WORK- AT SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND I AM IMPORTANT LIFT
AND I ASK FOR EVERYONE'S SUPPORT
BECAUSE THIS IS. MORE IMPORTANT
AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS TAURUS ARE DR SCOTT. MYERS
LIPTON PLEASE PROCEED. HELLO I
BACK. OF THE PROCESS. BUT AT
SOME OF THE YOU KNOW. ACTUALLY
TEACHES THEM WELCOME INCOME IN
THE- STARTED ABOUT FIVE AGO.
SURE THREE STUDENTS EVERY TIME.
WOULD AND TELL ME THE THEY WERE
H AT FIRST IT WAS SHOCKING
SADLY IS NOW THE NEW NORMAL.
I'VE HAD STUDENTS TELL ME THAT
THEY WERE SLEEPING IN THEIR CARS
THE CAMPUS LIBRARY THE STUDENT
UNION. AND BENCHES RIGHT OUTSIDE
MY OFFICE. AND THEY'VE TOLD ME
STORIES ABOUT WHEN THEY WAKE UP
THEY WALK ACROSS CAMPUS TO THE
SCHOOL GYM TO TAKE SHOWERS BRUSH
THEIR TEETH. THE PUT ON THEIR
MAKEUP BEFORE CLASSES START. AND
I SPENT MANY AFTERNOONS TRYING
TO FIND A PLACE FOR MY STUDENTS
TO SLEEP AT NIGHT. TRANSACTION I
CAN'T I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
DEBILITATING IT IS FOR MY
STUDENTS HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT NOT
ONLY THEIR ACADEMIC
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT ALSO TO
WORRY ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE GOING
TO SLEEP THAT NIGHT. CLEARLY
BEING HOMELESS FOR THE CALLS TO
NOW THE NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THEIR
GRADES. AND A DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON THE OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH.
AND FOR ME IT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND
UNJUST THAT THIS IS HAPPENING IN
OUR STATE TO MY STUDENTS. MY
PERSONAL STORY IS SUPPORTED BY
THE RESEARCH SHOCKINGLY 11% OR
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND CSU
STUDENT. EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
FOR AT LEAST ONE NIGHT PER YEAR
WITH 40% OF THE STUDENTS PRUDENT
SECURE. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE A GUARANTEED INCOME
PILOT PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ENTERING COLLEGE WITH
MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT ALL WITHOUT
IMPACTING THE FINANCIAL ISSUE
FINANCIAL AID. SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE DIRECT CASH PAYMENT OF A
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH FOR
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS WHO ARE
HOUSING INSECURE. WILL HELP THEM
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS IS A
TRANSITION FROM HIGH SCHOOL TO
HIRE AND- EMPLOYMENT. I STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO REDUCE
THE STUDENT HOMELESS AND
INCLUDING SECURITY STAFF I CITED
EARLIER. PERSONALLY IT WILL HELP
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS I
SPEAK WITH. EVERY SEMESTER WHOSE
GRADES SUFFER DURING THE
STRUGGLE WITH HOUSING AND
SECURITY AS WELL AS BRING MORE
STUDENTS INTO MY CLASSES. WOULD
HAVE NEVER THOUGHT THEY GET TEN
COLLEGE DUE TO FINANCIAL ANOTHER
CHAT FINANCIAL AND OTHER
CHALLENGES I HEARD YOUR SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. AT THE
END OF THE INNOVATIVE SOLUTION
TO BUY STABILITY FOR STUDENTS
DURING A FEDERAL TIME IN THEIR
LIFE. IT'LL REDUCE COLLEGE
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD
INSECURITY THANK VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW GO TO
MADAME MODERATOR TO QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHES SORRY LET'S GO
TO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES. TO STATE THEIR NAME
IN SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. HELLO
YET ANY MY YOUNGER POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OF MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND SUPPORT. FOR S.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. A TICKET
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- HE YOUR MIND ONE
TWENTY BUT IT WAS GOING TO GET
ANOTHER ITEM RIGHT. ALL RIGHT
PLEASE RE QUEUE UP AGAIN. NINE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JONATHAN GO ON WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I'M
ALSO A STUDENT THAT HAS
STRUGGLED FINANCIALLY AT TIMES
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE THREE FOUR
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
. NINE ONE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR CAP AGAIN
OFTEN ON BEHALF JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING EVERYONE FIGHTING THE
START UP LOOK AT THE ITEM WITH
YOUNG AGAINST THE OLD
CONSTRUCTION PORTER SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CARRY ONLY WITH
ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT ACTION
WHERE THE SPONSOR OF THE FELT.
VERY PROUD TO BE SPONSORING IT
THANK CENTER COURT TV REYES
LEADERSHIP FRAZIER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR OR THERE'S NO
LEAD OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE SEEING NO ONE ABOUT A
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA COME BACK
TO YOU AND ASK FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME AND
OPPOSITION TO SB. THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO LINES INTO AT
THIS TIME IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR ALL RIGHT
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SEEING SENATOR PAN PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU ANSWER
CORTESE I DO APPRECIATE THE THAT
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL I GUESS THE- MOUSE'S POINTS
OUT I THINK TO SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT SOME OF THE DETAILS ON
IMPLEMENTATION- I GUESS FOR
EXAMPLE- ARE WE- THE STUDENTS
ARE RECEIVING THESE FUNDS ARE WE
GOING TO HELP THEM GET BANKED-
ARE. YOU WITH ME TO GIVE THE
MONEY SO THEY NEED TO KEEP IT
SOMEWHERE RIGHT AND THEN PERHAPS
SOME FINANCIAL EDUCATION THAT
GOES WITH. UNDERSTANDING WHAT
NEEDS TO BE BANKED AND NOT
UNBANKED AND- HOW TO USE YOUR
MONEY AND SO FORTH- SO MAYBE CAN
SPIEGEL TO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THE WHAT YOU'RE THINKING IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION- SO THE
GOOD NEWS IS IT IS NEW IS A
GUARANTEED INCOME INCOME
PROGRAMS TEND TO BE WE HAVE SOME
EXPERIENCE WITH STANDING THEM UP
IN CARE COOLEY LAST YEAR'S
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
EFFORT RALPH FOSTER PREGNANT
WOMEN IN- DEBIT CARDS HAVE BEEN
USED- THUS FAR LOCALLY WITH
LOCAL PROGRAMS IN BETTER CITIES-
THAT'S WHERE THE STATE'S BEEN
HIDDEN TO AVOID THE- THE
COMPLICATIONS OF ISSUING CHECKS-
PEOPLE HAVING OPEN UP BANK
ACCOUNTS THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THEM AND SO FORTH- ONE OF THE
THINGS I DON'T WANT TO GET. OFF
TOPIC VERY CLOSELY RELATED IS
THAT- WRITTEN INTO THE
LEGISLATION- YOU COULD ACTUALLY
SEE IT ON PAGE FOUR- IS SO
SOMEONE WAS AT THE MINISTER
MAKES UP IN KIND CONTRIBUTIONS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FIND OUT TO MAKE AN INITIAL
MENTORSHIP SERVICE FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHICH WE FOUND IN.
OTHER PROGRAMS LOCAL AND STATE
IS- GENERALLY FORTHCOMING AS YOU
MIGHT IMAGINE- BANKING
INSTITUTIONS CREDIT UNIONS AND
SO FORTH. THE SAID SHE WANTED TO
PROVIDE OR OFFER THOSE SERVICES
FREE WITHOUT MANDATING THE
STUDENTS TO DO THAT WHICH- KIND
OF GETS IN THE WAY OF. THE
GUARANTEED INCOME APPROACH BUT
MAKING IT AVAILABLE AND IN SOME.
SUBSCRIBE TO IT- WHICH WHICH AND
CAN ALSO HELP. YOU KNOW JUST
WITH THE- SORT OF THE SMOOTHNESS
OF MAKING SURE THAT THEY
RECOGNIZE- WIN MONEY- IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND WHAT THEY
CAN DO WITH IN TERMS OF BANK IT.
MIGHT AS WELL AS IS WAS NOT
MAKING MISTAKES IN TERMS OF
THEIR DECISIONS AND CHOICES
SPENT. I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
THINK YOU KNOW YES- IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION RIGHT- SOMEONE
TAT IS HOMELESS- ALSO DAY DON'T
HAVE- WELL YOU LOSING STRAIGHT
THINGS AND IF YOU HAVE A
PERMANENT. PLACE AT CETERA AND-
THERE'S OTHER FACTORS AS WELL
WHICH- THE CHECKOUT SO IT'S
CERTAINLY A SUPPORT YOUR BILL I
WANT YOU TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON IT- I HAVE HAPPENED
TO BE ON HUMAN SERVICES I GUESS
I GET ANOTHER BITE AT THE APPLE
AND SEE HOW IT'S OF ALSO ON THE
RISE AND HUMAN SERVICES CELL- SO
BUT I'D- BE HELPFUL TO SORT OF.
GET SOME OF THESE DETAILS AND
AFTER YOU'RE TALKING A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S WELL. WORKED OUT- IT'S
THE BILL VOLS AND- SO WITH THAT.
WOULD BE VOTING FOR THE BILL
TODAY LOOK FORWARD TO ITS
FURTHER EVOLUTION TERMS AND
IMPLEMENTATION SUPPORT THE
PURPOSE OF THE L. THAT THE
GENERAL IDEA OF THE BILL. AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO MOVE TO BUILD
THE PERFECT TIME THANK YOU
CENTER PAN ANY FURTHER.
QUESTIONS OR VIA CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU SENATOR I NOTICED- THE
BILL. WOULD REQUIRE THAT
INDIVIDUALS EITHER COMPLETE
FASTER OR THE DREAM ACT
APPLICATION BEFORE. THEY CAN BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FUNDING BUT I
WAS UNABLE TO FIND. A
REQUIREMENT. THAT THEY HAVE TO
EITHER BE ACCEPTING OR PLANNING
TO ATTEND COLLEGE IN THE FALL.
IS IT YOUR INTENT. THAT THIS
MONEY. SHOULD BE USED TO HELP
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TO
WILL BE ATTENDING COLLEGE IN THE
FALL OR WOULD THE FUNNY BE
AVAILABLE FOR SOMEONE WHO IS
GOING TO GO STRAIGHT INTO THE
WORKFORCE- BOTH. BOTH AND SO THE
STAFF SAYS NOW ALMOST
UNIVERSALLY- TAKEN OUT BY.
RISING FRESHMAN OR EXITING-
SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO
PRIOR- ACTS OF THE STATE- SO
WE'RE JUST. TIED TOGETHER IN
THIS ENROLLMENT PROCESS THE
FILLING OUT OF THAT FORM SO THAT
THEY ARE READY FOR WHAT I HOPE
WOULD BE THE VAST MAJORITY WHO
ARE GOING ON TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION HOWEVER THEY'RE GOING
TO PUNISH PRESSURE PROGRAM AT
THE PREPARE THEMSELVES FOR- YOU
KNOW CAREER TECH OPPORTUNITIES-
WORK THEY'RE JUST THEY'RE GOING
DIRECTLY INTO SOME WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITY. OF LIKE ONE OF OUR
ENERGY COMPANIES IS OFFERING FOR
EXAMPLE SILICON VALLEY RIGHT NOW
WHICH TAKES HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
AND PUTS THEM RIGHT INTO- HI
LIVING WAGE PAYING JOBS- THE
WORKING IN THE ENERGY SECTOR
THAT'S FINE TOO. I WAS USING
THAT AS AN EXAMPLE ONLY IN HERE
BUT- THE ANSWER IS BOTH IN. SO
IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE GOING
STRAIGHT IN THE WORK FORCE
WITHOUT GOING TO LIKE A CAREER
TRAINING OR- ON THE JOB TRAINING
WHICH YOU'RE GETTING PAID WHEN
YOU. TYPICAL THOSE CORPORATIONS
ARE ON THE JOB TRAINING AT PAID
AT THE SAME TIME. SO I GUESS I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF YOU
IF YOU'RE NOT ON TRACK TO
GRADUATE ARE YOU STILL.
AVAILABLE TO RECEIVE THE FUNDS.
IF YOU'RE A LOT OF TROUBLES
SURGERY ARE YOU COULD BE AT A
GRADE LEVEL BUT NOT BE ON TRACK
TO. ACTUALLY GRADUATE DUE TO A
CURRICULA THAT THE BILL IS
INTENDED TO BE- FOR GRADUATING
SENIORS. GRADUATING SENIORS OF
FOR THAT PERIOD OF TIME BETWEEN
SENIOR GRADUATION AND WHEN
COLLEGE WOULD COMMENCE HOWEVER
THERE AND IT DOES NOT MANDATE
THEM TO ENROLL IN COLLEGE SO
IT'S IF I MAY IF I MAY TRY TO
PUT THE LENS ON IT THIS WAY IT'S
FIRST AND FOREMOST OF A STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS BILL AS STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS AS DEFINED IN IN-
BASED ON ON THE DATE OF THE
MCKINNEY VENTO ACT AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY SECONDARILY AS I
DISCUSSED IN MY PRESENTATION- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO DO
INTEND TO ENROLL- IN IN COLLEGE
WERE CAREER ACTIVITIES. DURING
THE SUMMER MONTHS ARE SUPPORTED
DURING THAT TIME IT HOPEFULLY
GETTING THEMSELVES OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU CENTER
DOLLY ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER PANDER TO MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH INDEED
WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON
THESE THINGS I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS VERY MUCH AS WE GO
ALONG IT'S GOING TO HELP US
CLARIFY- THINGS THAT FRANKLY ARE
A REALLY ARE ON THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE TO MAKE
SURE. YOU KNOW IT WORKS PROPERLY
SO HOPEFULLY BY NEXT COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE- MORE ANSWERS TO SOME
OF THOSE QUESTIONS SO THEY WORK
ON THAT AND I SIMPLY WANTED TO
DO SOMETHING I DIDN'T DO. IN THE
BEGINNING- IN. WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN MORE RESPECTFUL TO MY
WITNESSES IS TO- PROBABLY
IDENTIFYDR SCOTT MYERS LIVED IN
AS- A ONE OF THE LEAD AUTHORS
ACTUALLY THE LEAD AUTHOR OF
SOMETHING CALLED THE SILICON
VALLEY PAIN NDEX REPORT. WHICH
VERY MUCH INFLUENCES PROPOSAL
BECAUSE THE DATA THAT WAS
ALREADY THERE WERE SOME OF WHICH
HE CITED. A CRISTINA TOWARDS- I
THINK- SELF IDENTIFIED- WITH THE
WHO IS A YOUTH ADVOCATE WITH THE
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
IN A CURRENT STUDENT AT
BAKERSFIELD CLIMATE SO I JUST BE
ABLE TO DO WHAT I USUALLY DO IT.
I PROPERLY IDENTIFIED THEM AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE. THE
BILL HAS. BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAM. MENEM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI- TO ABOVE. COURTESY HI
PROTECT THE AYE DALY. TELLING
NOW GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI PAN
AYE THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE
DOWN. TO OUR FINAL TWO BILLS
WHICH HAPPEN TO BE MINE AFTER
THE OVER TO SENATOR OCHO A OKAY
SENATOR IT THE FULL. GOOD MORE.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR. LEYVA MAY
PRESENT YOUR FIRST S. B. FIFTY
FIVE GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A GOOD MORNING MEMBERS ON
NINE FIFTY FIVE ENCOURAGES
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS BECOME MORE
CIVICALLY ENGAGED IN OUR
GOVERNMENT AND OUR COMMUNITIES
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WILL ALLOW
ONE DAY EXCUSED ABSENCE PER
SCHOOL YEAR FOR MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN A CIVIC EVENT
CURRENT EDUCATIONAL PRIORITIES
IN CASE OUR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS
SEVERELY LIMIT THE TIME
AVAILABLE FOR CIVICS
INSTRUCTION. YET STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN A CLEAR CORRELATION
BETWEEN YOUTH PARTICIPATION IN
CIVICS FUTURE VOTING HABITS AND
ENGAGED CONSTITUENCY WETHERBY
PARTICIPATION IN A RALLY OR
TESTIFYING AT A COMMITTEE
HEARING LIKE THE ONE HERE TODAY
STUDENTS GAIN A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THEIR
DIRECT INVOLVEMENT CAN CHANGE
THE WORLD AROUND THEM IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CIVIC LEARNING
AND ENGAGEMENT BOTH WITHIN AND
OUTSIDE OF THEIR FORMAL
EDUCATION. SB NINE FIFTY FIVE IS
ONE SMALL BUT IMPORTANT STEP IN
THIS DIRECTION TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
LEVINE OR ALVIN LEE AND JENNIFER
TRAN FROM CHEN AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA- AND DO
YOU HAVE A PREFERENCE BETWEEN
WHICH WITNESS YOU WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE. I DO NOT RISKS OKAY I'M IN
LET'S BEGIN WITH- ALVIN LEE ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YEAH YOU GET
YOUR- IT PERFECTLY PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU FOR. ALL RIGHT
A GOOD MORNING SHARES THAT
CHEERLEADING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ALVIN B. A RECENT BAY
AREA PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CHN
UP CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
NEWSLETTER EDUCATION ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND WE ARE THE
PROUD TO SPONSOR SB NINE FIVE
FIVE. WHEN SERVICES TALKS LIKE
QUALITY LEARNING PRACTICES
ASSOCIATED WITH ONGOING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT ARE DISTRIBUTED
EQUITABLY FOR EXAMPLE MANY YOU
EIGHTY CLASSES IN PREDOMINANTLY
WHITE DISTRICTS AND IN FAMILIES
OF PARENTS WITH COLLEGE
EDUCATION ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO RECEIVE THE BEST EDUCATION.
AS A RESULT THE SITUATION BEST
POSITION TO REACH AND PREPARE
ALL USED FOR DEMOCRATIC
PARTICIPATION MEETING A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER. OF YOUNG
PEOPLE HI. THESE DISPARITIES.
SHOULD MUST PROVE. AND PRIOR TO.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BOTH WORDING
INTO THE CAN GET. UPSTREAM
POPULAR THAT I PER. IN KEY IN
DEMOCRATS PARTY. THIS FOR A
HEALTHY TO. THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
IT INFINITELY EASIER FOR
STUDENTS TO VOLUNTEER AND BE
MORE CIVICALLY ENGAGED TRULY
FOSTERING A CULTURE AND A
GENERATION OF CONSISTENT AND
SMART VOTERS. SB NINE FIVE FIVE
IS A CRUCIAL STEP TOWARDS
REQUIRED OUR DEMOCRACY IN MAKING
SURE THAT ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
POLICY CAN BEST SERVE
CONSTITUENTS WHEN I WAS A
STUDENT LEADER ORGANIZER IN HIGH
SCHOOL I CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THE CIVIC IT
AND USED IT TO FORGET QUALTRICS.
I GET UP TO VOTE OR LIKE-
SENATOR LEYVA MENTIONED YOU CAN
TESTIFY WITH THESE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND CALLED. HITTING THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. FINALLY I
RECENTLY JUST BECAME OLD ENOUGH
TO VOTE COPYRIGHT FIRST OF
REVOKING THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE GOOD MENTOR
YOU'LL RECALL ELECTION. I FOR
FAITH OUR STATE GOVERNMENT WILL
DO EVERYTHING IT CAN TO SUPPORT
YOUTH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IN THE
NATION'S LARGEST EDUCATION
SYSTEM. THANK YOU SENATOR ABOR
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THE COMMITTEE
I THOUGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER LEE- NOW CAN.
WITH JENNIFER TRAN ARE YOU ON
THE PHONE. OKAY WE'LL JUST WAIT-
JUST A BIT. I'M SORRY
MISTRANSLATIONS DROP FROM THE
LINE SHE SHOULD BE DIALING BACK
INTO. PERFECT THANK YOU.
YEAH WE CAN GO TO SUPPORT IN THE
IN THE ROOM AND ON THE LINE THE
COMPACT PERFECT SO WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY FIVE AM
WILL BEGIN- IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. JUST MAKE SURE THE
RIGHT ROOM THIS MORNING- IN
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED DO WE HAVE
ANY- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. C. NINE.
MATTER MODERATOR SHE WE JUST
CONTINUE WITH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. TWENTY
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
DURING. NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LEVEL
ONE MY NAME IS JONATHAN GO I'M
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NINE ONE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT.
NINE ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
AUDIBLE CHEN MEMBERS FUNDING
LEVEL COURSE OF CLARK- THE
RECENT GRADUATE AT THE BAY AREA
THE FORMER STUDENT NUMBER OF THE
ALL OF ALL THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF EDUCATION
CONGRESS SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
HOUSE SPEAKER IN SUPPORT AND WE
DO HAVE. THIS TREND THAT ON THEM
. PERFECT HI. HELLO OKAY A GOOD
MORNING. NUMBER FOUR A POINT
AFTER SHE HEARD IN YOUR ENTIRE
SCHOOL I SERVICE BUT- ALL THE
DIRECTOR FOR BOTH GENERATIONS UP
IN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SB
SIX WHAT PRODUCT OKAY REPORTER
THAT SB. NINE I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT I UNDERSTAND. YOU. WE
GET INTO THE READ THAT DIFFICULT
SPENT I THINK WE CAN BETTER
AFTER TO BE A ACADEMIC SHE I CAN
SHOULD BE THREATENED DEMOCRATIC. IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE. OKAY IF
THIS ANY PROGRAM IN THE FIELD
CAN GET ANY BETTER DRIVE. I NINE
FIVE FIVE WELL PLACE SB NINETY
FIVE ALL.
EIGHT ENGAGING VETTING
PROTECTING IT WILL DEMONSTRATION
TO RESCUE AND TRYING TO BROWN
AND TELLING THEM THAT WILL BE
PUT WITH THE ON THE ACADEMIC
RECORDS DOING THE VERY THING WE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU. WE KNOW THAT
THEY CAN GET ONLY ACADEMIC IN
AND EXTRACURRICULAR ENGAGEMENT
BUT ALSO BEATING COULD BE A LIVE
MARKET. WORK THAT YOU WE MUST
REMEMBER THAT WE ARE NOT SEEKING
YOU NEED TO DO BUT LEAVING THE
THAT I THINK. I CAN GET YOU MY
AND MAKE AFRICAN AND KNOWLEDGE
OF THE SYSTEM STATEMENT AFTER
FACT APPLY TO AND AFFECT TRUTH
ALL THE- I URGE I SB. THANK YOU
. OF JENNIFER FOR CALLING IN
WELL NOW CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM
OUR- OUT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINETY FIVE ARE WE NEED TO.
BE THE TELE. LINE THANK YOU
MADAM AND ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR IS
OPEN GO AHEAD WHEN WILL PLEASE.
NINE ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING-
HI MY NAME IS VICTOR KOSTELANETZ
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION FOR STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND WE VOICE
OUR SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL NINE
FIVE FIVE. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND CHECKING LINES JUST ONE
MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OTHER APPS.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF NINE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINES IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR HAVING HER FROM
ALL SUPPORTED WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY REGISTERED LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. SO WE WILL CONTINUE
WITH ANY- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. NINE FIFTY
FIVE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SCENE NINE WILL NOW
CONTINUE WITH WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIFTY FIVE
FOR WAITING TO TESTIFY THE OTHER
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIFTY
FIVE. MADE PRESS ONE AND THEN
THE GENERAL. WE HAVE NO LINES IN
Q. IN. OF ESPIONAGE FIFTY. IF
YOU MATTER MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE THE LINES WERE MORE
TIME TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL THE- WHAT IS IN
OPPOSITION OF IT AS- AND FIFTY.
PLEASE THANK YOU MAY CHAIR AND
ONE AGAIN LADIES AND IF WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AN UPPER OF NINE TO
FIVE YOU MAY BE ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO LINES AND-
THANK YOU MADAM. AND THANK YOU
TO ALL OUR WITNESSES THAT CALLED
IN TODAY WILL NOW BE BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TERM. TO HAVE A
TO ANY BERMAN HAVE ANY OR
COMMENTS. REYES THANK YOU WILL
FIRST THAT- I UP AND SHE THE
GRAY GOALS THAT THIS BILL
ADVANCE CIVIC EDUCATION OVER
IMPORTANT AND THE MAIL THANK
SUIT LEADERS WHO HAVE JOY IN OUR
TODAY BECAUSE THEY HAVE EXAM.
SAID UP A. ONE- IT SEEMS WHAT WE
WANT AND I APPRECIATE THEIR AND
IN THE ISSUE AND THEIR PET TO.
TODAY I HAVE TO SAY THAT I AM
STRUGGLING WITH THIS BILL.
DESPITE THE GREAT VALUES AND
GOALS BECAUSE- IT SEEMS TO OPEN
A PANDORA'S- AND I'LL TO GIVE
THE IDEA THEY WANT AUTHOR IT'S
TO MAKE ADDRESS. SOME OF CAN-
FOR- WE CAN'T REGULATE SPEECH.
AND SO STUDENTS WHO DECIDE TO
LEAVE SCHOOL FOR- THE PURPOSE
OF- ENGAGING AND- THIS KEPT THE
CIVIC ACTIVITY COULD DO IT FOR
EVEN EXTREMIST GROUPS SOME
GROUPS THAT THAT ADVANCE HATE-
AND SO THAT CERTAINLY. GIVES US
SOME PAUSE ALTHOUGH WE
APPRECIATE THE RIGHTS OF ALL
PEOPLE TO. EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS THAT- WE
SEEM TO BE STRUGGLING TO GET
STUDENTS TO BE IN THE CLASSROOM.
BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE-
STUDIES THAT ARE TAKING PLACE-
THE I DON'T RECALL OFF HAND HOW
MANY. SCHOOL DAYS ARE YOU
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TODAY AND HOW
THAT HAS CHANGED OVER TIME. I
KNOW THAT WE ARE ALL WORRIED
ABOUT LEARNING LOSSES WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND-
AND WE DO SEE DECLINING TEST
SCORES. SO WE KNOW THAT THE WORK
OF OUR- OF OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITY
IS- STILL WE STILL HAVE TO DO A
LOT MORE THAT SPACE AND A PART
OF THAT IS- STUDENTS BEING IN
THE CLASSROOM TO BE PART OF THAT
LEARNING PROCESS I WANT TO GIVE
THE AUTHOR A CHANCE TO. ADDRESS
THIS TO WORRIES THEY THINK VERY
MUCH CENTER GLAZER SO ON YOUR
FIRST QUESTION THAT'S WHAT WE
STRUGGLE WITH RIGHT IS IF WE
GIVE PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE IN THEIR CIVIC RIGHTS. WE
CAN'T I WOULD NOT WANT TO SEE
US. DISSUADE OR ELIMINATE THOSE
WHO ARE. IN MY OPINION LEGEND
LEGITIMATELY PARK PER TO A
PARTICIPATING IN CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. BECAUSE WE HAVE A
MINORITY OF PEOPLE THAT MIGHT
WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN SOME
NEGATIVE. HATE SPEECH TYPE-
EVENT SO I THINK THAT THE GOOD
OUTWEIGHS THE BAD- AND I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ALSO A WAY TO
LEGISLATE- OF FOR US TO
SUBJECTIVELY SAY. WHAT IS A GOOD
EVENT AND WHAT IS A NOT A NOT A
GOOD EVENT. I THINK THAT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IS IMPORTANT ENOUGH
THAT WE TAKE THAT CHANCE
SECONDLY- YES WE DO ON OUR
STUDENTS IN CLASS AND WE DO WANT
THEM LEARNING ALL THE IMPORTANT
CURRICULUM. BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY
AS A MOTHER OF TWO ADULT
DAUGHTERS SOME OF THE BEST
THINGS THEY LEARNED WERE DAYS
WHEN THEY GOT TO PARTICIPATE. IN
AN ACTIVITY OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
THINGS THAT STAYED WITH THEM FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES AND
THINGS THAT ENCOURAGE THEM. TO
TO JUST BE A PART OF OUR SOCIETY
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY VOTED
ENGAGE CIVICALLY. YOU ALL KNOW
THAT I WAS PART OF THE LABOR
MOVEMENT AND THEIR MANY TIMES
WHEN MY DAUGHTERS WERE. THERE
PARTICIPATING IN MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS AND THEIR LIFELONG
LESSONS SO I THINK THAT THIS ONE
DAY FOR CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
OUTWEIGHS ANYTHING THAT COULD BE
CONSTRUED AS A PROBLEM THANK YOU
THANK THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
AGAIN I SHARE-THE SENTIMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE WHEN YOU DO ENGAGE
IN THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY IT'S
REALLY CEMENTS THEIR
APPRECIATION FOR OUR- WONDERFUL
. DEMOCRACY IN REPRESENTED
GOVERNMENT LIKE- SO WE DO HAVE
SEX EDUCATION IN SCHOOL. AND I
KNOW THAT I REMEMBER MIND WHERE
THEY HAD A SAID YOU NEED TO
ENGAGE IN CERTAIN S. CIVIC
ACTIVITIES UNDER THE AUSPICES OF
THAT THE TEACHER. AND I
CERTAINLY AS A LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIAL LITTLE I SEE THAT
STUDENTS COMMAND- TO TEST AT OUR
CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS TO FOR
PHYLLIS CIVICS EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT. OF TESTIFYING OR
PARTICIPATING OR WRITING A PAPER
SO WE DO KNOW THAT- OUR OUR
SCHOOL LEADERS. EMBRACE THAT
GOALS OF THIS BILL IT BUT THEY
DO IT IN A MORE ORGANIZED
FASHION AND I GUESS THAT'S THE
THING ME PAUSE ON THE LOWER.
BEFORE US IS THAT. I THINK I'D
PREFER TO DEFERRED THAT LOCAL
LEADERSHIP. ADVANCING THE
IMPORTANT VALUES THAT YOUR BILL
EXPOSITOR APPRECIATE YOU BRING
IT FORWARD ABSOLUTELY AND I
THINK THAT IS. THAT IS AGAIN A
CONUNDRUM BECAUSE NOT EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND NOT EVERY
SCHOOL HAS A ROBUST CIVICS
CLASS. I CAN TELL YOU THAT MY
DAUGHTERS DID NOT GET A ROBUST
CIVICS CLASS WHEN THEY WERE IN
HIGH SCHOOL SO THIS IS A WAY OF
MAKING SURE. STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE WILL HAVE ACCESS TO SOME
OF THESE- CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES- I WOULD LOVE
NOTHING MORE THAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY SINGLE. HIGH SCHOOL
CLASSROOM- HAS A ROBUST CIVICS
CLASS BUT WE'RE NOT THERE YET SO
THIS IS A SMALL STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. IF YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
ANY COMMENTS. FIFTY NINE GUESS I
ROLES SOME OF MY- MY COMMENTS
AND OBSERVATIONS AND CONCERNS- I
THINK AS AS SENATOR GLAZERS SURE
I ALSO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE BELL- IN THAT ONE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE- OUR
CLASSES ARE GOVERNMENT CLASSES
THROUGHOUT DIFFERENT GRADES-
THAT ARE ACTUALLY THAT ACTUALLY
GIVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
TO BE ENGAGE YOUR WATCH AND LIKE
YOURSELF I WATCHED MANY OF OUR
LOCAL STUDENTS ACTUALLY ENGAGE
IN PROTEST AS WELL AS ATTEND
LOCAL- GOVERNMENT PROCEEDINGS-
OR VISIT JUST THE CITY HALL SO
STARTING FROM ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
ALL THE WAY UP TO HIGH SCHOOL SO
WE HAVE- YOU KNOW AS PART OF THE
CURRICULUM. THAT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GOVERNMENT
ENGAGEMENT TO OBSERVE HOW
GOVERNMENT WORKS AND WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE ENGAGED IN THAT
AND I THINK THE CONCERN THAT I
PERSONALLY HAD WITH THAT IS THAT
ALTHOUGH THE BILL STATES THAT
IT'S FOR ONE DAY AND OF COURSE I
SHARED. I'M NOT GOING TO ECHO
THE AB NOT GONNA REPEAT THE THAT
COMES OVER ME EARLIER BUT IT WAS
IT THERE IS A- A LINE HERE THAT
I ACTUALLY WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT AND THAT WAS WITH REGARDS
TO YOU- LINE. TWENTY THREE THAT
STATES- THE- ALTHOUGH IT'S FOR
ONE. DAY FOR THE PER OF A HIGH
MIDDLE SCHOOL MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
HIGH SCHOOL PEOPLE ENGAGING IN
CYNICAL CIVIC OR POLITICAL
EVENT. AND THAT RIGHT THERE WAS
A LITTLE BIT OF A CONCERN FOR ME
THE POLITICAL PART. AS PROVIDED
IN SUBPARAGRAPH AND THEN IT GOES
ON TO SAY THAT- IS REQUIRED TO
BE EXCUSE FOR ONLY ONE SCHOOL
DAY LONG ABSENCE PER SCHOOL
YEAR. BUT ON THE FOLLOWING LINE
IT SAYS THE MIDDLES- I'M JUST
GOING TO. SUMMARIZE YOUR BODIES
AS MAY BE PERMITTED ADDITIONAL
EXCUSE EXCUSED ABSENCES IN THE
DISCRETION OF THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR- AND NOT ACTUALLY
TO ME WITH A LITTLE BIT OF A
CONCERN BECAUSE ALTHOUGH THE
BILL SPECIFIES ONE DAY. IT DOES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE FOR A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME AND IN THE
FIRST PART OF BILLBOARDS AS A
POLITICAL EVENT IT MAKES ME A
LITTLE NERVOUS THAT WE WOULD USE
THIS AS A LOOPHOLE. TO HAVE OUR
CHILDREN. BEING GAUGE
POLITICALLY FOR POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS FOR LONG PERIODS OF
TIME- YOU KNOW WHAT EVERYBODY I
MEAN AT THE DISCRETION OF THE OF
THE OF THE OF THE LOCAL. SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AND I THINK FOR ME
OVERALL. ONE THING IS TO BE AB
THE HOBBIT OPPORTUNITY THROUGH.
THE SCHOOL TO BE ENGAGED IN
GOVERNMENT AND HOW THE
GOVERNMENT PROCESS WORK IN A
DIFFERENT STORY FOR ME
PERSONALLY IN THE POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN ARENA. AND THE REASON I
SAY THAT IS THAT I CAME INTO
THIS SPACE OUT FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME. AND IT WAS AN EYE
OPENER AND- IT WAS AN EYE OPENER
BECAUSE I REALIZE HOW TOXIC. OF
AN ENVIRONMENT IT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE. AND THERE'S A
LOT OF- THERE'S A LOT OF AB
NEFARIOUS ACTORS IN THE SPACE
WHERE THEY SHARE A LOT OF FALSE
INFORMATION AND- AND- I'LL JUST
LEAVE IT AT THAT A LOT OF FALSE
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE
INCREDIBLY MEAN AND VERY
HURTFUL. AND OUR STUDENTS WHICH-
DON'T HAVE THE LIFE EXPERIENCES
YET TO HELP IN THEIR DEVELOPING
OUT THERE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THAT I'M AFRAID THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE EXPOSED AND
THIS IS JUST ME BEING PROTECTED
HERE- BUT EXPOSED TO IT TO A
SPACE WHERE POTENTIALLY COULD BE
VERY HARMFUL AND- I THINK
THERE'S A REASON WHY WE HAVE A
VOTING YOU KNOW AGES OF EIGHTEEN
OVERCOME THE POLITICAL PART ON
THAT END AND ONE THING IS BEING
INVOLVED WITH YOUR PARENTS AND
SO FORTH AND ANOTHER ONE IS THE
SCHOOL ALLOWING OUR STUDENTS TO
BE EXPOSED TO AN AREA
POTENTIALLY BEING IN AN AREA.
WHERE THEY CAN BE USED FOR
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS I'M IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW THAT
ENVIRONMENT CAN CAN EVOLVE IN IN
CERTAIN AREAS IT JUST MAKES ME A
BIT NERVOUS TO FOR THAT BUT FOR
GOVERNMENT YOU KNOW- ENDEAVORS
HOW GOVERNMENT WORKS TO ME
THERE'S A CERTAIN LEVEL OF-
PROTECTION IN THAT SPACE VERSUS
LEAVING IT OPEN FOR A
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IT SAYS HERE
POLITICAL EVENTS AND THEN. EVEN
IT OPEN ONCE AGAIN TO YOU I.
EXCUSED ABSENCES IN THE
DISCRETION OF THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AND IF THERE IS-
AFFILIATIONS WITH A SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR WITH THE LOCAL I.
CANDIDATE IN A LOCAL PART IN
GRANITE. FOR ME THIS WOULD BE
FABULOUS BECAUSE I'M VERY ENGAGE
WITH MY AT MY LOCAL SCHOOLS AND
I HAVE GREAT RELATIONSHIPS SO. I
YOU KNOW. PASSING THIS WOULD BE
A GREAT EXPERIENCE FOR ME. BUT
I'M LOOKING AT AREAS WHERE IT
MAY NOT BE SO- POSITIVE ERROR OR
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONTENTIOUS. AND- AND THAT
ACTUALLY IT'S ALL GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THAT BUT
THAT IS THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE
RIGHT NOW THAT IT WOULD IT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE EXPLOITED. FOR
CAMPAIGN PURPOSES FOR PERSONAL
BENEFIT OF LOCAL- CANDIDATES
AND- ELECTED'S. SALATA IMPACT
THEIR SENATOR CHOI BOGUE BUT LET
ME I'LL GIVE IT MY BEST SHOT. SO
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT- TO YOUR
POINT SENATOR GLAZERS PONTS
ABOUT US SCHOOLS ALREADY DOING
THIS I WILL GO BACK TO WHAT I
pDOING THAT AND IF YOU BOTH ARE
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
DOING THAT THAT'S WONDERFUL. BUT
IT'S NOT HAPPENING EVERYWHERE UP
AND DOWN THE STATE SO THIS BILL
IS A SMALL ATTEMPT TO HELP THAT
HAPPEN SECONDLY I WOULD SAY
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT.
POLITICS IS A PART OF GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T HAPPEN IF
POLITICAL PARTIES DON'T ELECT
PEOPLE WE WOULDN'T HAVE SCHOOL
BOARDS WE WOULDN'T HAVE CITY
COUNCILS IF THOSE FOLKSWERE NOT
ELECTED WE WOULDN'T HAVE A STATE
GOVERNMENT. IF THOSE FOLKS WERE
NOT ELECTED SO POLITICS IS. THE
REASON WE ARE HERE AND HAVE A
GOVERNMENT. DO I THINK THE
PEOPLE COULD BE EXPLOITED PEOPLE
COULD BE EXPLOITED ON ANY NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT THINGS- AND I DON'T
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A REASON TO
NOT MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD. THIS
IS ABOUT ATTEMPTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT. YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND HOW
GOVERNMENT WORKS AND TO
UNDERSTAND AND IT MAY BE A
POLITICAL THEY MAY GO TO A
POLITICAL EVENT THEY MAY NOT
THEY MAY GO TO A SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING THEY MAY GO TO A CITY
COUNCIL MEETING. THEY MAY FLY UP
HERE AND PARTICIPATE IN ONE OF
OUR HEARINGS THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT THEY
COULD PARTICIPATE IN- THERE WAS
ONE OTHER THING YOU SAID THEY
WANT TO ADDRESS BUT IS ESCAPING
ME- AS- THE BILL. IS FOR ONE DAY
ONE DAY OF EXCUSED ABSENCE THE
PORTION YOU'RE READING. AT THE
SCHOOL CAN ALWAYS ALLOW STUDENTS
TO BE GONE LONGER- WHEN MY
DAUGHTERS WERE IN GRAMMAR SCHOOL
ONE OF THEM WHAT CUT EXCUSE FOR
TWO WEEKS FROM THE SCHOOL. TO
TRAVEL TO- HOLLAND WITH MY
HUSBAND BECAUSE WE FELT THAT HER
EXPERIENCE IN HOLLAND FOR TWO
WEEKS WAS GOING TO BE. I HATE TO
SAY THIS UP MORE LIFE CHANGING A
BENEFICIAL THEN THE TWO WEEKS
YOU WOULD HAVE SPENT IN FOURTH
GRADE. SO THAT IS ALWAYS BEEN
THERE AND THAT WOULD BE UP TO
THE DISCRETION OF THE SCHOOL
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THAT
THIS BILL. ALLOWS FOR ONE DAY
FOR A CIVICS ENGAGEMENT. I GUESS
TO THAT I WOULD SAY BECAUSE I
WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THE
CIVIC PART OF IT AND HOW. THAT
LINE BUT THE FACT THAT IT.
CREATES THE POLITICAL EVENT
PART. THAT'S WHAT MAKES ME
NERVOUS THAT'S INCLUDED IN THAT
WITH THAT WITH THAT IT IS
BECAUSE AS I EXPLAINED WITHOUT
POLITICS. WE DON'T HAVE CIVICS
AND WE DON'T HAVE GOVERNMENT
WHETHER WE LIKE OUR POLITICAL
PROCESS OR NOT. IT IS JUST THIS
IS HOW WE GET GOVERNMENT. I
AGREE I AGREE ON THAT AND THAT'S
WHY I ACTUALLY. THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT WHEN I SPEAK TO GROUPS
I. TRY TO ENGAGE OUR PEOPLE AND
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS SO I. I
GET THAT PART OF. BEING ENGAGED
IN BEING INFORMED- BUT JUST AS A
MINOR YOU KNOW THERE'S A REASON
WHY WE HAVE MINORS IN LAWS
PROTECTING OUR MINERS AND SO I
JUST. THAT'S JUST THE ONLY.
LITTLE RESERVATION THAT I HAVE
READ YOUR- SENATOR PAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CEREBELLAR- SO
FIRST OF ALL I GO TO PUT THE
BILL TO LIGHT KEEP TO KEEP
WORKING ON IT AT THE MET. I AM-
I DO SHARE SOME THE SAME. THAT
CENTER BOGUS SIX INTO OF. YES
POLITICS IS PARTICLE I MEAN WE
AREN'T THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
RIGHT NOW WE GOT DOUBTS. AND- MY
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN TO POLITICAL
EVENTS- BUT I THINK INTO OF IT
BEING A- EXPLICIT REASON FOR
EXCUSE SCHOOL. WELL THERE MAY BE
. BENEFIT I THINK THERE ARE-
SOME CERTAINLY SOME CONCERNS OF
IT BEING ABUSED ARE- PLACE
THEY'D BE USED TO IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW PUTTING. PERHAPS OF THE
SCHOOL. WHOEVER ELSE'S ACCEPTING
THAT AS AN EXCUSE IN AN AWKWARD
POSITION- AS WELL- AND SO- I DO
ADMIT I SHARED SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS I HOPE YOU'LL- ADDRESS
THOSE AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD-
BECAUSE THIS IS I MEAN THIS IS
FOR AND I IT CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WE SAID YOU KNOW NOT
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS DO THIS.
RIGHT- BUT TO CERTAIN EXTENT WE
DO NEED SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE SOME STRUCTURE AND- AND
PROTECTION AROUND THE STUDENTS
SO THAT. IT'S TRULY AN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE-
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WHAT GIVE THE
LATITUDE TO PARENTS AS WELL WHO
WHO CHOSE TO THE ONSET THAT I'M
GONNA TAKE MY CHILD OUT OF
SCHOOL FOR THE DAY. AT I THINK
THAT'S AND IT IS ONLY FOR YOUR
POINT ABOUT WILL FOR MORE DAYS
THEY DO YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
DISCUSSION ETCETERA. IHAVE BEEN
AND I HAVE SOME ANXIETY IS A
WITHOUT THE POLITICS PART ABOUT
THE VULNERABILITY AND ALSO AND
FOR SCHOOL PERSONNEL EVEN IN
TERMS OF POTENTIALLY BEING
CAUGHT IN A AND A CHALLENGING
SITUATION- AT A- PARTICULAR
POLITICAL SITUATION. OF- IN
TERMS OF- THE USE OF STUDENT
TIME SO- BUT I CERTAINLY WANT
YOU KNOW THAT- WHAT YOU TO MOVE
MARTIN THE BILL FOR I THINK THAT
THIS IS A- AT YAHOO. SUPPORT NOT
TO. HAVE STILL HAVE THAT HAVE
HAVE THAT KIND OF EXPERIENCE AND
YOU KNOW SO. REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE VERSUS JUST IN AND-
VERSES JUST PERHAPS EIGHT BILL
IN THE- IN THE TEACHING
ENVIRONMENT SOMETHING- BUT- I DO
I CAN. I DO SOME OF THE CAN THAT
WERE EXPRESSED THANK YOU IT TO
BE CLEAR SCHOOLS CANSINO. SELF
YOU KNOW OR PARENTS CAN SAY NO
PARENTS CAN YOU KNOW AS PARENTS
WE HAVE A LOT OF. A LOT OF
CONTROL THAT SOMETIMES IS AN
EXERCISE BUT THIS ISN'T ABOUT
JUST- YOU KNOW ME NOT GOING TO
SCHOOL AND SAYING HEY I'M GOING
TO GO DO THIS OR THAT AND I'M
GONNA GET EXCUSE FOR THE DAY.
PARENTS WOULD HAVE TO ALLOW
THEIR CHILDREN IN THE SCHOOL
WOULD HAVE TO APPROVE IT AS
WELL. SO THERE THERE ARE
GUARDRAILS. YOU HAVE SEEN. THANK
YOU AND I WANT TO THE BECAUSE
HAVE A DOLLARS TO SEE. THIS IS
AN ANSWERS- WOULD ACTUALLY
HAPPEN SOME FOLKS PRICIEST
TAXING FROM TIME TO TIME HERE
BUT WE'RE OFTENTIMES GETTING
SOMETHING THAT ME FROM MY STAFF-
IN THIS CASE MY DISTRICT OFFICE
WAS TEXTING ME BECAUSE- FOR
NINETEEN YEARS PREVIOUS TO THE
PANDEMIC I'VE BEEN BRINGING UP-
A SO CALLED BUS TRIP TO
SACRAMENTO- WITH- AS MANY AS
FIVE TOUR BUSES FOR FOLKS TO
COME UP AND MEET. LEGISLATORS SO
LIKE MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND SO FORTH- TO TALK
TO FAMILIES- LOCAL CONSTITUENTS
IN CHILDREN- SCHOOL AGE
pUNDER THE BANNER OF- IN THIS
CASE- PLEASE GIVE REVIEWS ON
EDUCATION FUNDING THE IRISH OF
THE TRIP IF THEY'RE ALWAYS WAS
ONE IS OVER THOSE NINETEEN YEARS
AND BY THE WAY IT'S COMING BACK
THIS YEAR BUT I WAN TO THE
SHAMELESS PLUG WHAT YOU'LL KNOW.
SEVERAL OTHER- BUT- HE KNOW THE
MAY READ WHEN WE'RE ALL- GETTING
A HANDLE ON THE BUDGET BUT
THERE'S SORT OF AN IRONY IN IT
IS THAT PEOPLE START ASKING AS
JUST HAPPENED ON A TEXT MESSAGE
HERE WHILE WE WERE HERE IN THIS
BILL IS IT OKAY TO BRING
CHILDREN YOU KNOW- CAN I BRING
MY CHILDREN FROM SCHOOL OF
COURSE THAT'S A PARENTAL
DECISION FIRST AND FOREMOST BUT
IF THEY DO IT WITHOUT- A CREDIT
ARRANGEMENT WITH THE SCHOOL THEN
WE'RE PULLING ADL SCHOOL WE
BROUGHT AS MANY AS A HUNDRED
FIFTY YOUTH APPEAR. IN THIS A
HUNDRED FIFTY USE TIMES OF
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH MEANS WHAT
WE'RE FIGHTING. THE OF US WHO
CHOOSE THAT. FOR EQUITY IN IN A-
FUND- WERE. IN A VERTICALLY
CREATING A PRO HERE SO I REALLY.
THAT BECAUSE GOT TO BE HAPPY AND
DOWN STATE IN MANY MAY DIFFERENT
WAYS WITH. FOLKS WANTING TO
BRING YOU TO THE TOWN HALL
MEETINGS AND SO FORTH WE ALREADY
HAVE STATE STATUTE THAT SAYS A
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES WHICH ARE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE CANNOT ENGAGE
IN PARTISAN. POLITICAL ACTIVITY
LIKE CAMPAIGNS- I'M NOT SURE YOU
KNOW IF TO BUILD COMMITTEE WANTS
TO CALL THAT OUT OR NOT IT'S I
DON'T BECAUSE MY- MY PLAY I HEAR
THE CONCERN SO THAT. I KNOW IN
MY EXPERIENCE- ON. THAT SIDE OF
THE POLITICAL ACTIVITY- WHEN WE-
WANT TO ENGAGE YOUNG PEOPLE IN
IT IN THE EDUCATION SYSTEM. IN
ACTUAL CAMPAIGN ACTIVITY. MOST
CERTAINLY IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
REQUIRED THAT THE STUDENTS ARE.
INSTRUCTED THAT- THEY CAN OPT IN
OR OPT OUT ANY- CAMPAIGN OR
POLITICAL ACTIVITY OF THEIR
CHOICE NOT. SIMPLY THE ONE THAT
HAPPENS TO BE THE IMITATION
BEFORE THEM BUT- YOU KNOW IT
DOES SEEM TO ME ALREADY EXISTED
IN STATE LAW BUT IF THEY NEED TO
BE. CROSS REFERENCE SOMEHOW IN
THE BUILDING MAYBE THAT MAKES
PEOPLE FEEL A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMFORTABLE I CERTAINLY FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THE BILL THE WAY IT
IS AND IT'LL BE SUPPORTING THE-
THANK YOU. THEN THANK YOU. FOR
RECALLING ONLY. I'M SURE YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS IS WHAT WE'RE FOR
IS TO HAVE THE- ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE- AND BRING
IDEA THAT WE MAY. ALL HAVE- AT
THE TIME OF READING THE BILL- DO
YOU FOLKS HAVE ANY. ELSE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SAY WELL I'M LET
ME JUST GO OUT. AT LET ME JUST.
MAKE MY FINAL. AS I SAID- I
THINK. I THINK THE PERSONALLY
JUST THE ONLY CONCERN I HAVE IS
THE POLITICAL CAMPAIGN ASPECT OF
IT. AND I DO BELIEVE THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS
YOU CAN DO THAT AFTER SCHOOL YOU
HOW WE CAN EXPECT THE WEEKEND
STIFF YOU CAN ATTEND THOSE TYPE
OF EVENTS. DURING SCHOOL WE HAVE
GOVERNMENT'S CLASSES IN
GOVERNMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND I
KNOW THAT. WHEN THERE'S BEEN A
OPPORTUNITIES TO. ENGAGE IN
SOMETHING SPECIFICALLY. OUT OUR
SCHOOL WAS ALWAYS VERY JUST
RESPECTIVE ARE- RESPECTFUL AND
ACCOMMODATING IN IN TRYING TO.
GIVE THE STUDENTS THAT THE
RESPONSE THE EXPERIENCES I THINK
LOCAL CONTROL IS VERY IMPORTANT
IF LOCAL SCHOOLS ARE NOT BEING
ENGAGED. AND I SURELY HOPE THAT
THE LOCAL CITIZENS WILL.
ADVOCATE FOR THAT IN THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. ON ON THAT AND- SO.
BECAUSE EVEN IF WE MANDATED IT
UNLESS THE OPPORTUNITY DISCOUNT
IN THERE PROMOTED BY THE LOCAL.
EITHERTEACHERS OR PARENTS
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
UTILIZED- ITER SO. IN SUCH
YOU'RE NOT IN SUCH A THIS BEING
. IT WON'T HAVE IN RIGHT NOW I
THINK WITH WHAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE. IT CAN ALREADY HAPPEN- SO
THAT'S THE ONLY BECAUSE THAT
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT I
THAT I HAVE TO SAY. IT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE WOULD LOVE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU. MADAM A CO
CHAIR. SO YES IT CAN HAPPEN. AND
YES IF WE PUT THIS IN STATUTE IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT EVERYONE WILL
AUTOMATICALLY DO IT BUT WHAT IT
DOES DO. IS IT MAKES STUDENTS
AWARE OF IT SO IF LOCALLY THE
SCHOOL BOARD IS NOT ENGAGING IF
CITIZENS ARE NOT ENGAGING.
STUDENTS NOW KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
THIS RIGHT SO THEY CAN ASK TO BE
EXCUSED THEY CAN SAY SOMETHING
TO THEIR MOM AND DAD SAY HEY I
WANT TO BE A PART OF THIS. SO
PART OF THIS IS MAKING SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND AND THIS WILL BE
A LAW. THAT IS OUT THERE FOR
THEM TO SEE AND PARTICIPATE IN.
I WOULD ALSO MENTION I SHOULD'VE
MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAVE A
YOUNG SENATORS PROGRAM WE'VE HAD
IT FOR THE EIGHT YEARS I'VE BEEN
IN THE SENATE. IT IS- HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND WE BRING
THEM UP HERE AS WELL EVERY YEAR
WE HAVE AN UNFORTUNATE US TWO
YEARS BECAUSE OF COBIT. BUT WE
PUT THEM ON A BUS AND WE BRING
THEM UP HERE SO THAT THEY CAN
SEE. THEIR CAR. WERE SO THERE'S
A LOT OF WAYS IN A LOT OF. FOR
US TO HELP OUR STUDENTS BE
CIVICALLY ENGAGED. TO HOPEFULLY
BE BETTER ADULTS- AND BE MORE
ENGAGED AS ADULTS. THIS BILL IS
ONE SMALL PIECE OF THAT I
RESPECTFULLY HOUSE FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SENATOR
LEYVA AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST. BE RE. BE
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE AND
APPROPRIATIONS- WE HAVE A
MOTION. SIR MOVED BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU. FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT S. B. NINE FIVE
FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI LEYVA OHIO TO ABOVE NO
PHOTOBOOK NO COURTESY PROTEST
THE AYE DALLY DAILY NO GLAZER.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN AYE PAN
AYE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
FOUR VOTES AND THE BILL PASSES.
WELL NOW AND MOVE ON TO YOUR
SECOND BILL SENATOR LEYVA SB
NINE SEVEN SIX WHICH I JUST WANT
TO START AND I AM A CO AUTHOR.
IMPORTS HER TO MAKE UP AND JUST
BE A LITTLE PIECE TO THEIR
PREVIOUS NO VOTE ON THERE BUT- I
AM IT. CO AUTHOR ON THIS. EARLY
BO GIVE FREE TO. HOW YOU. IT NOT
PROBLEM. A GOOD MORNING AGAIN
MEMBERS IT IS GREAT TO BE WITH
YOU ALL. I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON
PAGE EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS. THIS
AMENDMENT WILL INCLUDE-
EDUCATORS AND EDUCATOR
BARGAINING REPRESENTATIVES. TO
THE CD AND CD S. S. COUNCIL. SB
NINE SEVENTY SIX PROVIDES
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL BY ENSURING
THAT PARENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
HAVE INCREASED OPTIONS. WHEN IT
COMES TO CHILD CARE. CLEARLY
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO THAT
PARENTS CAN WORK AND PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. SB NINE SEVEN
SIX CREATES A FREE UNIVERSAL PRE
SCHOOL SYSTEM BY EXPANDING
ACCESS. TO THE STATE'S PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM TO ALL THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLD. REGARDLESS OF FAMILY
INCOME. THE BILL SUPPLEMENTS THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN BY
STRICT STRENGTHENING OUR CHILD
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE. MEMBERS THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC PUSHED
OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM. TO THE
BRINK OF COLLAPSE. MANY
PROVIDERS 98% OF MORE WOMEN WERE
FORCED TO CLOSE OR SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMIT THEIR ENROLLMENT DURING
THE PANDEMIC. CHILD CARE GROUPS
IN CALIFORNIA RELY ON SERVING. A
RANGE OF AGE GROUPS GIVEN THE
HIGH COST OF INFANT AND TODDLER
CARE. AS YOU MAY KNOW THIS IS AN
INDUSTRY THAT EMPLOYS WOMEN OF
COLOR PRIMARILY. WE MUST CREATE
A SYSTEM THAT NOT ONLY WORKS FOR
FAMILIES BUT ALSO UP LIVES AND
PROVIDES. UPLIFT PROVIDERS BY
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO OPEN THE DOORS TO
MORE. CHILDREN AND PAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES A LIVING WAGE. SB NINE
SEVEN SIX STRENGTHENS CHILD CARE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND PROVIDES
FAMILY WITH MUCH THE FAMILIES
WITH MUCH NEEDED FLEXIBILITY. AS
WELL AS OFFER STABILITY TO THE
CHILD CARE COMMUNITY. WITH ME IN
PERSON TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
DONIS GARINGER WITH THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER. AND JUSTIN
BLAKELY FROM CRYSTAL STAIRS WILL
BE JOINING VIA TELECONFERENCE
LINE. TO SPEAK AND SUPPORT
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK. YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
WILL WITH. IN PERSON WITNESS.
DONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO. WITH
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
MEMBERS AND SENATOR LEYVA FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THIS BILL. MY NAME'S
DONNA SNARE DRUM THE VICE
PRESIDENT CHIEF STRATEGY OFFICER
FOR THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER. WE'RE A NONPROFIT CHILD
AND FAMILY DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN BOTH
SAMPOERNA DINO AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AND OUR MISSION IS TO
CULTIVATE CHILD FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY WELLBEING WE REALLY
BELIEVE THAT ACCESS AT EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO A DIVERSE ARRAY OF
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS IS CRITICAL.
FOR OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
FAMILIES AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES THERE'S
BEEN A DECADES LONG PROGRESSION
TO OFFERING PRESCHOOL SERVICES
MORE BROADLY. MANY STATES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THESE MODELS WITH
VARYING DEGREES OF SUCCESS AND
THERE ARE MANY LESSONS LEARNED.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN FROM THESE OTHER EFFORTS
ONE THING IS CLEAR UTILIZATION
OF A MIXED DELIVERY MODEL WHICH
ENGAGES AND BUILDS UPON OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS INCENTERS.
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES AND HEAD
START. IS CRITICAL TO THE
OVERALL SUCCESS OF NOTONLY OUR
PRESCHOOL EFFORTS. BUT OUR
OVERALL SYSTEM OF CHILD CARE FOR
ALL CHILDREN BIRTH THROUGH
TWELVE. AND THEIR WORKING
PARENTS. IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE. THE CENTER FOR AMERICAN
PROGRESS RELEASED A REPORT
OUTLINING SIX KEY COMPONENTS FOR
A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THAT WOULD
SUPPORT A STRONG EQUITABLE BIRTH
THROUGH AGE FIVE SYSTEM THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE
DESIGNING A SYSTEM FOR PRESCHOOL
TO BE DELIVERED IN MULTIPLE
SETTINGS INCLUDING FAMILY CHILD
CARE SUPPORT HEAD START TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND TO SERVE MORE
PRESCHOOLERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. INVEST IN
INFANTS AND TODDLERS IT
EXCLUDING THEM FROM INCREASE
FUNDING WOULD UNDERMINE OUR
OVERALL SYSTEM ENSURE EQUITABLE
ACCESS AND QUALITY BY DIRECTING
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PLAN TO SERVE TARGETED. AREAS IN
GROUPS OF STUDENTS PRIORITIZE
PROVIDING EQUITABLE COMPENSATION
TO EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
EDUCATORS REGARDLESS OF SETTING
AND LASTLY ENSURE THAT ALL
PROGRAMS PROVIDE A PLATFORM THAT
VALUES FAMILY VOICE AND SHARES
POWER WITH FAMILIES. WE ARE JUST
ABOUT TWO MINUTES WOULD YOU MIND
WILL GO QUICK. FOR CALIFORNIA TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN DELIVERING
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL WHILE NOT
HARMING THE FULL SYSTEM OF CARE
WHICH SUPPORTS CHILDREN FAMILIES
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY IT'S
CRITICAL WE ENGAGE THE FULL
FIELD. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO CALIFORNIA TOOK A
STEP FORWARD WITH UNIVERSAL
PRIEST TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
WE BELIEVE SB NINE SEVEN SIX
WILL TAKE THE LESSONS. FROM THAT
AND BUILD UPON IT TO CREATE THE
FOUNDATION FOR MIX DELIVERY
COMPONENT OF UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
. IT WILL DO THIS BY A SETTING
THE TABLE FOR KEY STAKEHOLDERS
ENSURING THE ENGAGEMENT OF ALL
TYPES OF PROVIDERS TO MEET THE
AGE AND DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS OF
OUR CHILDREN. AND ADDRESS THE
BROAD SCOPE OF NEEDS OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS THAT ARE VERY BIG AND
DIVERSE STATE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CO SPONSORS I'D LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR LEYVA AND HER STAFF AND
WE'RE EAGER TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON ANY OTHER ISSUES
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE
WILL NOW MOVE FORWARD WTH
JUSTIN BLAKELY ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. JUSTIN YEP THE MORNING KIT
IS MY IDEAL CLEAR. VERY CLEAR
YES PLEASE PROCEED. PERFECT
PERFECT. THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR- THE MORNING- ADAM
BY SHEER NUMBERS THAT THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE- MY NAME AND
STUFF AND LIKELY I'M THE PUBLIC
POLICY APPROPRIATE CRIPPLED.
THEIR CRYSTAL CLEAR OF THE NON.
PROFIT CHILD DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION TURN OVER FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. AND COMMUNITIES OF
SOUTH ANGLICANS AROUND. AROUND
THE AREA ANKLE. CRITICAL CARE TO
PROMOTE- PROGRAM THAT STRENGTHEN
AND THE- FAMILY SOURCE REACHING
UP THE BUSINESS THE- PROVIDING
IN RICH LIVE THEIR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THEY- COOKBOOK THERE
DIDN'T STRONG SUPPORTER AT BEING
I COULDN'T. WE WILL THAT WAS A-
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE
FAMILIES WITH THE OPTION TO SEND
THEIR CHILDREN TO PUBLIC SCHOOL
PROVIDER OR A TRUCK- COMMUNITY.
BASED PROVIDER OF THEIR CHOICE.
CALIFORNIA AREA SIDE STRUCK.
CULTURAL AND WITH HE- SB NINE
SEVEN FICKLE OUR FOR TO CHOOSE
WHICH I THINK IT FOR THE FOR
THEM THEIR CHILDREN A MAKE THE
LIVER APPROACH TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT THE THING PROVIDER NET. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IS THE ONLY
WAY TO HAPPEN IT'S GOING NEED
WERE THEY ARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I KNOW WE'RE ALL WE'RE
THAT THE CAN ACTED IT CHAPTER
PROVIDER IT OR- PROCEEDS AFTER
AT A FOR THE ENTIRETY.
ADDITIONALLY ALSO WILL BE THE
READY BE ON A LARGE SCHOOLS AND
IT WILL NEED A QUOTE BILLION ARE
OF THAT PROVIDES I'M AREN'T IN
PLAY LEARNING IN THE SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN FAMILY DOCTOR
LAKE ELEVATING THE THAT HAVE A
COLD NURTURING. THAT MEETS THE
OF OUR AND LOCAL TO THEIR TO SO
WE'VE NOT. OUT OPTIONAL FROM OUR
FAMILIES OF ITS FROM BEEN IN
THEIR VERY EARLY YEARS OF
DEVELOPMENT AND LEARN ALL
CHILDREN ARE DFFERENT SB NINE
AND BIG FOR THE KNOWLEDGE OF
THAT MIND SHARING FAN CHOOSE THE
PROVIDER THAT BEST AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY. OPTION FOR
THEIR CHILDREN THERE ARE MANY
REASONS THAT BEING MADE TO THE
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDER
INCLUDING NEED FOR CARE DURING
NONTRADITIONAL HOURS SET THAT
THE CLEAN OR NIGHT SHIFT THE
ABILITY TO BE THEIR HOME
LANGUAGE PROXIMITY PREPARING
WORK OR HOME AND IN OTHER
CULTURAL REASONS. ENACTING
UNIVERSAL BEFORE THEM THROUGH SB
NINE SEVEN SIX FOR HOLDING
ADEQUATE THE FOR ALL FAMILIES
JEFF COLYER KNEES JUST OVER TWO
MINUTES WOULD YOU MIND- JUST
WRAPPING UP YEAH COMMENT. YEAH
NOW OUR RAPID RIGHT THANK YOU-
SO IT'S ACTUALLY YOU KNOW HOW
PRICES ON ITS THESE PEOPLE
LANGUAGES SO RAIN WHICH IS WHY
WE MORE THAN A UNIVERSAL FACT
THAT BALK LUCIEN MARKET WE NEED
A CALIFORNIA PEOPLE THE THING
TRULY UNIVERSAL NON UNIFORM
THANK YOU DEFENDER LEYVA FOR HER
UNRELENTING SUPPORT. INDIANA
CHAMPION FOR ART SO. AND
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS WHO PAID
CARE OF THEM ROB CAL. SB NINE
SEVEN WITHIN ORGANIZED THAT WILL
HELP EARLY. AND EDUCATION. OVER
TO THE ENTRANCE RIGHT SYSTEM
THAT LIFTS UP SUPPORT AND I
EVERY TYPE OF PROVIDER S.
RETRIEVED BY RESPECT REQUEST.
I'VE ON IT BE NICE IF IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST.
WILL NOW MOVE IN TO HEAR FROM
ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE IN PERSON
ROOM TO TWO HIGH. S. B. NINE
SEVENTY SIX. HI YEAH ANYMORE YOU
WITH SALUTE ARE BEHALF OF SLOW
VALLEY COMMUNITY. IN SOME OF
THIS THANK YOU. HELLO DAVID HAS
BEEN- REPRESENTING CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ACROSS STATE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING YOUR SUPPORT THE WHAT
VOTE SUPPORT VOTE NEXT YEAR I
THOUGHT THANKS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SEEN NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED FULL
MOVED TO OUR WITNESSES WAITING
TO TEST FIVE YEAR TELECONFERENCE
LINE- MODERATE IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND. OPENING THE LINES FOR
THOSE WITNESSES I WOULD LIKE TO
CALL IN IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVENTY SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND ZERO. NINE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CATIONS A- WITH A CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
NETWORK A CO SPONSOR THIS DOWN
INTO. LEAVES THE PORT. LINE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME I
MAYA CHARLES I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN COUNCIL SAN
FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT SB NINE
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE OF CRANK CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CANDOR KERR IN
STRONG SUPPORTER TO BILL AND
VERY GRATEFUL TO SENATOR LISA
FOR HER LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ADELAIDA
K. CALLING ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA AS THE CROWD
COSPONSOR OF THE BILL WE'RE
INSTRUCTED ANYTHING GIVEN. NINE
ONE THIRTY SEVEN THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE HAD A
NEED NOT KNOW WHAT'S OF THERE
NOW TRUMP FAILING AN EARLY A
COURTEOUS. MY THIRTY TWO YOU
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DONNA HOFFMAN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF COUNCIL FOR A STRONG AMERICA
READY NATION FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS AND MISSION
READINESS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO YES. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. HI MY NAME IS ALEA
FERNANDES AND ALMOST SEVEN THREE
SIX SEVEN FISCAL. AND I SUPPORT
SB NINE SIX THANK YOU. LINE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND SENATORS ROSANNA
KARAKTER ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION FIRSTHAND AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS NEED PRO ALL
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION OR KAPPA IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS EVEN ACT WHERE
ON BEHALF OF THE LEARNING CARE
GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT AND HAVE
TO BE NICE SEVENTY. NINE ONE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU EVERYBODY MY
NAME IS KARINA LIKE A LITTLE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU. ONE ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS. LAURIE WITH VOICES
FROM FRANCISCO I'M CALLING
SUPPORT OF. NINE SEVEN SIX FOUR
CENTER AND NAY BUT LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS QUITE ABLE TO SKI WITH
THE- SANDY CAL CALLING IN STRONG
OF. NINE SEVENTY SIX. THANKS THE
LABOR FOR HER. NINE ONE NINE
YOUR LIFE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAMILLEWORKING WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF THE LEARNING
EXPERIENCE CHILD CARE CENTERS
AND FOR THE BILL. NINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE NEW LARA MACINNES
STARTER ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
TELKOMSEL OF CINEMA COUNTY AND
ON BEHALF OF NORTHERN DIRECTORS
GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE ONE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS VALERIE TOMORROW WITH
EVERY HOW CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
PROBABLY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASKING NINETY SEVEN POINT. NINE
ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH YEAH
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE- WE ARE
TWEENERWE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION OF AS WE WORK THROUGH
OUR CONVERSATION- WITH A BUMPER
AND AUTHOR BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT.
FIRST STEP IN MAKING SURE THAT
WERE WORKING WITH OUR EXISTING
CARE WORKFORCE A COMPUTER IT-
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
GOVERNMENT THAT YOU TO YOUR
CONVERSELY ABOUT THE GET TO
SUPPORT. MY ONE FIFTY FIVE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO. HI MANY
MYSTERIES LAND MOTHER OF A TWO
YEAR OLD ENOUGH YEAR OLD A
STRONG SUPPORT L. A. THINK
THEY'RE REALLY GROUP. LINE ONE.
SIX YOUR LINE IS A PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT THE MAKE OUR FUTURE
COUNCIL SENT TO CALLING IT FOR A
ESTEEMED SEVEN. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE FURTHER IN THE FOR A NINE
SEVENTY SIX IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MATTER MODERATE YOU WOULDN'T
TAKING THE ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL OUR SUPPORTERS FOR SB
NINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL OUR SUPPORTERS
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION. WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION.
ON THIS BILL CONGRATULATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA. AB WE'RE NOW
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SEVENTY
SIX HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SCENE NINE. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS- MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE SEVENTY SIX. THANK
YOU MANAGER AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVENTY
SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO LINES IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
SEVENTY SIX. AND JUST PER
PROTOCOL AND TO BE FAIR WOULD
YOU MIND CHECKING THE LINES ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES TO SB NINE SEVENTY SIX
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVENTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ZERO WE HAVE NO LINES IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU TO
ALL OUR SUPPORT- THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR- AND THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES- WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY WILL NOW BE
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE. WE MOVE IT YEAH BUT
MOTION BY SENATOR- MCGUIRE. AND
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS A MAN
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE AND HUMAN SERVICES
MAY CLOSE MA'AM QUIRK-SILVA I'M
SORRY I APOLOGIZE OKAY. BUT
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY- THIS BILL IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO FOR-
CHILD FOR WORKING PARENTS- THIS
BILL WE HOPE DOES FOR PRESCHOOL
AND DAYCARE WHAT T. K. DID FOR
FOUR YEAR OLDS SO WE ARE VERY
EXCITED TO WORK ON THIS BILL AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A PROPER
CARE FOR OUR CHILDREN SO THAT
MOMS AND DADS CAN GO TO WORK AND
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS ARE
LEARNING WITHOUT A- ASK. AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER LATER AND
WE HAVE A BY SEN- BUT WHY. WHILE
I NUMBER SB NINE SEVENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE OCHO ABOVE I
WHICH OBERG COURTESY YE.
COURTESY AYE DALY. GLAZER GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PANTS
ALL RIGHT I. SIXTH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE AT BUILD PASSES
WITH SIX RELIEF IT OPEN. UP ILL
LEAVE THE AB OPEN OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
HERE YOU GO. I THINK YOU MA'AM
COCHAIR PRE YOUR HELP- THOSE
BILLS. IN ONE WAY OR NOW GOING
OPEN THE ROLE ON ANY- ON ALL OF
OUR BILLS- MADAM CONSULTANT
LET'S START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR CONSENT
SHARES VOTED AYE VICE CHAIR HAS
VOTED I FURTIVELY AYE FERTILITY
AYE MCGUIRE TH REQUIRED FOR THE
USER THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS-
CONSENTED- SEVEN ZERO WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO A FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
ARE VOTE ONLY BILL PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
CHAIR VOTED ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTED NO CORTESE PROTESTS THE I
GLAZER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
THAT'S FOR VOTE THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES AND IS OUT WE WILL
NOW- BEEN CANCELED YOU WANT TO
GO IN THE FILE ORDER OKAY VERY
GOOD WE'LL START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB TEN SEP FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT ALREADY HAD SEVEN
VOTES INITIAL BEAUTIFUL THANK
YOU FILE ITEM TO FIX BROKEN WAS
ALBERT NOW BOY WE ARE ON A ROLL
HERE FILE ITEM THREE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING ON AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE PAN SIX ZERO THAT BOOK BILLS
OUT SIX ZERO THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW GO TO FILE ITEM SEVEN WE.
HAVE ANY ABSENT MEMBERS. YEAH AT
THE THAT WAS ORDERED TO HAVE IT
IS ONE AND I BELIEVE IT'S FORTY
OF FOR THANK YOU THAT BILLS ALL
AND I BELIEVE- FILE ITEM EIGHT
NINE WE HAD A FULL VOTING
MEMBERS I KNOW SENATOR DOLLY HAS
HE DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIS COURT.
CORRECT OKAY. PART CAN YOU CALL
THE CLOTHES OUT NUMBER AT A
LOCAL MORE TIME YEP LET'S GO DO
THE ROLE ON ON NUMBER NINE SB%
NINE SEVEN SIX FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE S. B. NINE SEVENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE YOU'RE
VOTING ON. VALLEY IF SIX ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT SIX ZERO ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAD A LONG
HEARING TODAY. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND YOUR COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED. YOUR JOB EVERYBODY.
WE'RE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE IS
ENDING NOW PLEASE H